hello everybody and happy Friday it is
June 2nd and we are here
[Music]
and the face of impossible adversity
right and here's something that I'm
proud to say we've done a week of Fairly
awful shows
but today on this Friday we have
prepared for you guys an actually good
show
okay but you guys are gonna so this is
the one you guys are going to want to
watch this one is gonna be really good
thank you I feel blessed to be a part of
the best job
absolutely yeah of course uh today's
sponsors are hexclad and Native who we
love love our sponsors oh yeah
we are obsessed upset
um uh Marvel Teddy fresh comes out next
Thursday do you have anything you want
to show
uh
uh yeah it's actually okay but
coming this week assets to get approved
yeah so yeah working with a large IEP
it's a it there's a lot of moving Parts
but the bigger they are
like as a corporation like 10 million
you know it's funny they said that
they're a family business Disney the the
people of Mickey Mouse family I don't
know they literally said that
you mean like the the people we talked
about Marvel is a family business the
Marvels I don't know I was like us too
but you're is mom and pop operation over
there at Marvel
uh and also um ela's Vlog you got a new
Vlog coming out tonight I've been
working on it it's coming out tomorrow
you guys better watch it
it's a threat is this one good unlike
the other ones yes this one is actually
good
the other ones are very good the other
one's like yeah you're sl you're giving
me um poison ivy oh okay cool fun thank
you showed off get fit for the day
and best
oh oh we're keying out
because it's all green wait we don't oh
we don't have a key it's on wait why do
we have a key on we're usually we're
just normally the shot has it and it
forgot to turn it off there it is there
it is yeah she's green
all right thank you so poison ivy does
like seductive kisses that's her power
she has like Paul in that
hypnotizes people so
she's a sexy plant
hypnotized me Mommy
so that's all fun good things
um we have doors we have no working
bathrooms we have no doors so
um
so you said that the doors are more
expensive to fix than we thought you
said it was 150 I know so when I saw
Jeremiah before the show he was like I
got a quote it's only 150 for the door
and I was like oh awesome yeah and then
when I heard you guys talk about it I
was like oh it's only 150 like go for it
yeah then yesterday when he saw me he
was like so I got the quote and it's uh
600 for labor and I was like wait what
to put a door on I was like wait I
thought I thought we were talking about
150. hold on hold on hold on 600 to put
a door on some hinges and my class you
guys 1200 this week hold on hold on hold
on and then and then right after I heard
that um people were telling me they just
did a third door with Hassan yeah we did
we broke them off but it was worth it
but that's gonna cost us two grand
almost 1800. I wonder because maybe if
somebody comes to do all three at once
but I'm not understanding the the
logistics you're talking about the door
and putting it on hinges right it they
took the hinges off like college took
the hinges off the fuckboy's hand yes
they don't want you to put a new door in
no I'm serious how long does it take to
install the door 10 minutes heavy
[__] doors in and I carried him up
with Jeremiah up the stuff did we have
to buy the same Fort Knox ass I so I I
told Jeremiah well now it's three so I
think he's looking into [__] it let's go
potential either quotes
but uh that was funny well we I can I am
going to do everything I can to keep the
door breaking uh moving because
um I think I think everybody in this
office at some point needs to break a
door
right and so everybody everybody at one
point in the song there used to be uh
rescued from inside the bathroom
right it's um it's a social experiment
yeah break
okay well two thousand dollars
we're supporting working people what
more could you have true
the doorman The Carpenters
we support our local.org
we're in The Fifth Element keep breaking
stuff and he explains that it's right
destruction you know provides people
with things to do and everything sure
you're like an evil Overlord basically
sure I mean I don't like that you don't
like the comparison not exactly it's not
a one for one not one for one
uh exciting update Lego hard rejected
our submission for the H3 podcast Studio
boy that exciting it's not so here Ian
tell us what happened
okay so the first time and the second
time so when I originally submitted it
says is this an existing IP
and I say yes and they go let us know
what it is I type in H3 it auto fills
and says H3 podcast so okay someone must
have already submitted something so I
click in and I immediately get an error
message go we The Lego company have
assessed this intellectual property in
the past and we've deemed it
inappropriate for our brand wow I get
that we never I never talked to the Lego
people in my life yeah and they're
already hating or reputation proceeds
I refuse to believe
I'm too invested in this Lego set I want
it to happen they're very PC do you want
to read the bullet points yes what they
don't accept as IP because I think
you'll find it fairly okay well hold on
okay the second time Ian you want to
explain what happened yes so what I did
was then I marked that it's not an
existing IP change the name to just
podcast Studio
add that I photoshopped out all of the
logos so if you scroll to the second
image you can see what it looked like in
that gallery or the third image sorry
there it is what is this nobody knows
generic logo it's just a podcast that's
it that's all yeah and then if you go up
one Dan uh use chat GPT yeah this like
random generic Babble about podcasts and
I read this first paragraph unleash the
vibrancy of the podcasting world with
podcast Studio A meticulously designed
Lego set celebrating the transformative
power of podcast
that's not bad
Rejoice podcasters around the world
somebody said submit a steady fresh and
I'm thinking the same thing why you want
to get blocked at the daddy first
blacklisted too no I want to get this
set to happen
it's been marked yet but even after all
that then we got this which said they
still knew it was H3 podcast what so is
there a is there someone watching the
show who's a double agent for Lego
um why would they do that to us we're
we're all obsessed with Lego here okay
but here's the good news they say
unfortunately we had to return your
product uh for further revisions to
comply with our guidelines I says okay
great we can do that uh note the license
properties related to these topics will
not be approved so let's see which ones
can we eliminate politics political
symbols campaigns or movements
I don't I mean in the set there's no
political symbols it's not about that
it's about the IP hold on politics just
politics well maybe the leftover set
yeah the leftovers it's not even part of
the show it's a different show Dan right
differently it's part of the Lego set
and also again it doesn't have anything
to do with the Lego set itself it has to
do with the IP all right well okay so we
we can we can let's stop talking about
politics that's fine okay you're
thinking very limited mine right now
keep reading religious references
including symbols buildings or people we
don't do that
no really there's actually a reference
to a religious building on this show
that got into a lot of trouble then what
the Vatican Limited
mindset of the sensing today hold on
you're telling me open your mind
that I can't even have mentioned Vatican
City ever
and are like nearly thousand episodes
that can't be true
I don't think it's the mention that's
the problem
okay fine uh well we can we can reform
sex nudity drugs or smoking I mean we
have talked about drugs although we're
not doing drugs we did drugs on the show
last month doing huge bomb grips right
but that was last month what drugs
technically nobody knows if anybody did
anything yeah we didn't so true okay
well we we can I mean this is
entertainment they can change us alcohol
in any present day situation
what are they against day drinking
swearing or profanity what the [__]
all right I can get I can I can change
for you Lego
death killing blood terrorism they got
us there
bing bing bing bing bing
first person shooter video game
we are good we are not a first person
shooter video no I think we passed that
one everybody
I'm surprised you didn't try to explain
how we're using computer videos we
thought you were gonna bring up payday
we did play a half-life and you guys are
in Payday so also we did the green
screen competition which was me with the
gun potentially pretending to be in a
yeah but that's third person because we
could see you it wasn't from your POV
not for sure
Warfare or war vehicles and any modern
or present-day situation oh good so that
we can do antique War
or national war memorial so we can do
like Civil War [__] which is cool good
okay good to know or Star Wars
can we do Trail of Tears does that fit
in the oh see then they say racism oh
wait yeah they have all the Star Wars
sets I mean there's death and killing in
Star Wars
all that stuff alcohol highlights all of
these yeah so there you go but not for
you Lego I see how it is there's no
point in reasoning with the Danes
hold on
oh I keep Zach no he has a point and
here's why I said this last time and I
believe it's true this IP is too
important to leave in the hand of the
Danish people America must invade the
country of Denmark and occupy them until
we can assure that Legos is being
controlled ethically and humanitarianly
just like the oil reserves in uh Iraq
and and Afghanistan and all over the
Middle East we as the American uh
Patriots and moral Arbiters of the world
it is our duty
to invade Denmark I'm scared because
whatever
Shredder just said something no Shredder
yeah oh no
what happened
maybe he's trying to get to food is it
food there's food on the table wait
don't leave food on the table guys I
think I left my foot on the table
that's definitely what it was yes
Shredder you snitched on yourself
is there food is there a lot better
don't give me a heart attack but there
was there wasn't really okay oh okay
thank you Elena we are bringing
democracy to Lego City I was gonna say
that I'm not ready to talk about
dethroning whoever is running Lego
because they know what they're doing
thank you ELO have you seen any other
franchise that makes such fire
playsets listen any any Lego set goes so
hard and the quality is so good they
know what they're doing I wanted a
regime change okay come to them if they
want to comply okay or if they want to
be uh if they want to revolt yeah we
need to deliberate them
we gotta bring freedom to Denmark I'm
scared of this I'm scared of opening
this conversation
and then they say racism bowling or
cruelty to real life animals that one
they got us on Big Time yes yes yes hey
Gabe hey
I just want to say it's summertime baby
let's go
I'm so happy it's summer although summer
technically starts Gabe
oh yeah yeah summer technically starts
on June 21st
technically but the one that says summer
right now right
[Applause]
what's happening
is that water or oil are you getting
oiled up oh Gabe we're doing are you
being waterboarded
Gabe Gabe we're trying to get in with
Lego we can't show any like cruelty
because totally to animals torture
humans are animals
are you okay
I'm good
it's refreshed for the summer it's only
70 degrees today the Hat
that most people is beautiful
how you doing how was your week
oh it's good it's good
it's good any uh any specifics you want
to share or we'll just keep that close
to the chair
yeah do you have any tickets for me I
would appreciate it
anyone got some tickets to the Yankees
Dodgers game going spare
anybody
nobody in this office but uh we'll keep
our eyes open all right so yeah wait are
you a Dodgers fan or a Yankees fan you
know the answer it's all the way
and I got [__] for you Gabe I got [__]
yeah don't you remember when we got that
unique look inside this living room
where yeah the Yankees were losing and
it was like it was it was awake in there
it's pandemonium no it wasn't a Panama
it was just straight up wait bro oh
right because I'm right right
yeah that was great oh yeah which movie
it's called shooting stars LeBron James
wait LeBron he's uh he's still trying to
act wait you went to the premiere
yeah really great red carpet oh it's an
NBA it's red Carthage she went to the
red carpet for the LeBron James what did
what did you wear do you have pictures
it's on Instagram
oh
I'll pull those up I want to see Gabe
I'm going I'm going Gabe on the right
carpet so any big plans this weekend my
Friday my brother and Friday
I'm trying to gear up to the Yankee
starters game okay we have one goal
yeah if you go online and try to scalp
tickets from like or I guess yeah from
like these third-party sellers how much
do those run right now are those prices
front row is like a thousand
um yeah
shooting star there's Gabe
okay did you see any cool celebrities
there what is this
one who is that dude
yeah that's Coolio
that's Coolio
Coolio
one of the actors in the um okay okay
his name's Julio
that's already taken
yeah rip to the goat oh I guess it's
fair I guess he can be cool yeah it's
available he's in you might say he's in
gangsters paradise
yeah
line how much is it for Yankee Dodger
games tickets I mean you're not We're
not gonna go in front row we'll take
anything right we'll take notes please I
think it's great man yeah all right I'm
there baby let me see how much it is are
you talking about the game tomorrow
tonight or tomorrow oh no
how many tickets do you need
just one just one are you just going by
yourself what about nickname yeah what
about Nick
yeah you got his ticket
okay hold on hold on he's probably going
with his dad his dad was a die hard
so Nick Nick and his dad have tickets
good tickets because they do not yet oh
nice yeah
don't do at some point
would be comfortable going and sitting
by yourself or would you try to sneak
over to them no I'm not I'm good by
myself wow you're a lone wolf dude
you are the confidence
you see any tickets on there uh I just
got to June 2nd I see the game I see
some for tomorrow
what are we talking tonight or tomorrow
Gabe what are we talking tonight or
tomorrow
um anytime on the weekend so today
tomorrow oh you'll go anytime by
yourself Lone Wolf status there's this
single game there's a single Ticket
available for tonight's game directly
behind the plate
one available it's eleven hundred
dollars
that's not bad because the one ticket is
so bizarre right wait is it in Dugout
Club Dan uh
uh no
okay hold on hold on hold on but I'm so
confused are they playing a few times
isn't it it's a serious yeah play a few
games yeah you want a weekend yeah yeah
a lot of baseball players are crazy
that's crazy they're in different
leagues okay hold on guys hold on Gabe
if we buy you this ticket right behind
home plate
it's one thousand one hundred dollars
today will you go
sure sure
let's go
it's not that enthusiastic
come on why not no one wants a free
trips
wait are you excited or not I think he
is of course I'm excited yeah well that
was like a tick tock wow
so Gabe if I get this ticket can you
take some footage for us and just come
report back
maybe on Monday or yeah we can hear
about your big day at the game sure
let's go all right Gabe is going by
himself
and you're gonna be sitting in show me
the show me where the seat is I want to
know how crazy the seat is
uh uh do you want
when let me get the ticket first tonight
like what time we'll just send in the
thing and we won't put on screen well
I'm already off that's I'm already up
I'm too far down the rabbit hole give me
a second Dan is buying the ticket as we
speak Gabe
thank you
guys we got you dude appreciate you guys
we got you forever through thick and
thin yeah
[Applause]
ex video you know narrated I want to
know how's the game going I wanna know
how close you are you know so I'll tell
you what Gabe those seats that are
really close I got my dad once those for
his birthday they have like a buffet
that you could get and eat whatever you
wanna it's called Dugout Club it's
unlimited hot dogs and Dugout Club Gabe
Fried Chicken
so if you can film the spread
yeah
can you film the food for us at The
Dugout Club
pure okay great and then how many
friends my hero baby no you're my hero
uh Dan is in the uh Matrix right now I'm
about to check out
he's about to check out do you think
when your requirements should I buy the
ticket protection Gabe are you going oh
he's going sure okay because I'm
declining the ticket protection right
now sure is not the best I think that's
just okay we do not want ticket
protection we do not no hell no okay
do you think when you're at the game you
could get the crowd to start chanting
who the [__] is Uncle game
Uncle game who the [__] is Uncle game
who the [__] is okay
can I ask you a question can you can you
try and film yourself trying
yeah 100
that's what's up and while we can ask is
to try can we can we throw in one
condition can he wear a Dodger hat
instead of a Yankee hat oh God
it's like hell no we're gonna need that
ticket protection that's not gonna get
us in with Lego
no Gabe you're there to support your uh
Yankees and Yankees baby there already
are these are transferable right because
I'm not putting his name anywhere in
here this won't be like a problem
Gabe
[Laughter]
this type is I mean it's just asking for
the name on the credit card well that's
okay
sure you can you can handle to somebody
else yeah hey maybe ask Lina because she
did it for your dad yeah
well then I'm then I'm I'm clicking
order what platform are you using
I'm just buying from the Dodgers website
MLP oh it's the Dodgers website
mlbtickets.com
I thought you were on a third party no
there was a ticket available
directly I don't know that those are
transferable oh
no why wouldn't they be right well that
should be easy to answer just Google it
I mean our Dodger tickets
you guys should ask
you so when I bought the um Elton John
tickets I was able to transfer those to
you guys and I'm looking up the Dodgers
tickets now yeah but that wasn't
directly from the venue was that on like
StubHub
why would that matter I had to upload it
to the Dodgers um Stadium website first
in the app and then board it to you guys
all right Dan you're going to the Dodger
game tonight everybody's saying yes you
can I mean it's transferable yeah
there's got to be we'll get the yeah
that seems great okay forwarding tickets
my Dodger tickets can uh you can forward
tickets to friends colleagues and ticket
Partners all right we're good we got two
games in the bad we got the ticket
you guys are the fan no you're the best
yeah what time is the game start
uh it said like uh seven oh it does it
what no it starts at seven
that's so late it's that's so 11 10 P.M
holy [__]
you stay up that late cape yeah why yes
Friday yeah it's Friday baby come on
it's Friday are you gonna drink are you
gonna drink there by yourself
100 that's what I'm talking about
the Lone Wolf status all the way we got
the ticket
oh I think my dad's I hear my dad just
texted me oh my dad says he has tickets
for tonight oh
Dad look for Gabe right behind the uh
home plate
smash that button
can you pull up the chart I want to see
where the seat is I want to see how bad
uh yeah here now that now that I got it
I just didn't want somebody in the
audience to go swipe it yeah
who the [__] is Uncle gay we're probably
gonna see you on TV yo anyone watching
the game try to peep try to keep our boy
all right view tickets here we go
uh somebody said not everyone has
like yeah I'm looking at the ticket it
doesn't have a name on it so it's just
yeah it's just a QR code so this should
be fine
um how are the players like at full
energy at that hour like I wonder how
they prep the whole day also the Yankees
there on the East Coast time too so yeah
oh my God for them I don't know baseball
players are insane athletes like they're
crazy they do they do so many games and
they travel so much
I don't know how they have any quality
of life yeah my dad is asking where's
his ticket
I'm uh pulling up I'm going to show you
exactly where it is
yeah can you I want to see just film
everything you're eating over here it
even shows you
the perspective you ready oh that's your
seat oh oh my God you see that yeah it
says Dugout glove right yeah
that's the benefit of being a lone wolf
dude that's sick
you're in the fifth row you're in the
fifth row behind home plate
yeah this isn't the exact same it's like
a row next to this yes but this is
basically the scene
you've got that all you can eat man f is
Uncle gay well I'm excited for you okay
who the [__] is
awesome
too many times
hey Gabe we found your uh
Gabe do you do you have beach balls at
home to bring with you [__] ball
I don't I don't think so I don't even
know what that means
you know when you you bring a beach ball
and you throw it for everybody to play
beach ball [__] that beach ball I don't
like that
my dad brings up my dad brings a knife
to games and he deflates them with his
pocket knife yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I'm gonna like how you go Dan is
going to send you all the ticket info
just uh we'll we'll talk to you on
Monday just give us a nice little uh
report I want to know how was your time
just film everything get drunk try to
start that chant who the [__] is Uncle
Gabe maybe maybe wear something really
bright so we can spot you on TV yes El
Don Elton John Dodger uniform wait do we
have something you can wear like bright
neon hahaha
I don't know uh
we'll work on it we'll work on the
details yeah thank you Gabe I'm very
excited for you God bless have fun
goodbye again every Friday
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't have got me hearing hearing
Ian push the button
silent and I just hear it click click
click all right have the best time okay
Gabe okay
[Applause]
my dad said let's see he says we're at
Lo uh
see move us there my dad says
that was the only Ticket available that
was it but he said that whole section
was sold out but one loan that is so
freaking awesome my dad says um where's
my ticket basically they can't even go
say hi to Gabe they're not even allowed
in that section that button dude that's
a badass they got like a private
entrance to get in there man can you do
me a favor go to a third party website
uh somebody and just see how much those
tickets go on the after market sure see
what kind of deal we got for our boy
Gabe well that was wholesome that was
very cool you know he deserves the best
uh
[Applause]
foot soldier he's not even he's a
general he's a colonel
or whatever Brigadier Brigadier General
I think Colonel is the one right below
General I believe okay so that feels
appropriate are you not cold it's like
no
crazy here I'm not cold but you can turn
it the temperature down here fine so um
on the roster today we've got a bunch of
great stuff uh we have a guest here
which I haven't announced yet but you
guys are gonna love it
um we have a PowerPoint of I don't know
if you all been following this phase
Reign drama you know insane oh so phase
um signed this girl Grace Van Deen she
was an actor on Stranger Things okay she
was the uh
I don't like this so that's her okay
they signed her to phase and FaZe Rain
who's I guess a founder
he started getting all butt hurt
what about because he thought she was a
uh affirmative action hire
he said go home gamer girl he goes you
don't really literally said to her you
don't even know what a trick shot is he
actually said that no but the beef
started to intensify and then they met
in person and she started and she
started crying she said if you post that
I'm Gonna Leave face and he posted it
it's crazy drama what oh yeah
wait okay I guess we will talk Olivia's
prepared in a PowerPoint yeah I'll take
you through her I'm excited for that and
then um we got a whole bunch of other
stuff but right now
friend of the show we've had him on one
time he did a call in and he's now a
resident of Los Angeles so we have the
pleasure of having him on in the studio
his name is Malik lazri and you might
know him better as
the flashlight guy
the flashlight guy here he is the
legendary
you guys might remember he called in she
better shut her it's okay cheddar
Shredder cheddar cheddar is actually
dope what's up
Shredder chill
Raider look it's okay I love dogs so
here we're joined by Malik and in that
uh what's to be industrial strength
explosion proof briefcase is the most
valuable
items in your extremely valuable I
couldn't find my handcuffs otherwise
it'd be handcuffed okay because it's
that valuable yes so is this okay yeah
oh uh not for Lego
yeah you're good you're okay cool
um so we're calling them flashlights
right because that's what they are or
units I like to I like to call them
units oh that's great yeah because I
mean the unit could be anything really
right so you guys might have seen some
of Malik's Greatest Hits on Tick Tock
and they are some of my favorite videos
of lighting up the runway this this one
here is a limited edition like the uh
teacup from Beauty and the Beast I
actually haven't made that one yet
like a Beauty and the Beast one didn't
you
um no actually there's no no Beauty and
the Beast but the teacup is like I don't
know it's a little bit like I know
absolutely yeah because the teacup is
actually like a small child he's a
really sweet child but the what do you
call this thing right here
the kettle that's [__] oh absolutely
he's like completely of age I think
she's like a MILF to be a so um I gotta
ask you about this hat oh I made this
hat did you it was actually my late
grandfather's hat okay
you see
yes uh-huh see what it says there that's
like a text like hell it's yours this
hat belongs to Bob Graham yeah Bob
Graham who was actually a professional
um Quick Draw
he was like the fastest gun it's Prada
legit product huh yeah yeah I don't know
it's like too late okay cool man you
know I love bootleg Can't Get Enough
you've moved out to Los Angeles right
yes so what brought you out here to La
um honestly I don't know the State of
Affairs in Austin and the rent started
going up you know the big Tech started
moving in which is I mean I great but
Austin is a small town so so you're like
well I might as well just move to LA at
this point absolutely and I found a
place at the exact same rate
that often is getting expensive then
that is shocking to him because there's
no like uh rent control in Austin so
it's like they're just it's not okay wow
they don't care so here uh if you guys
might better remember him here's one of
his iconic uh units this is a repurposed
um unit that was made uh Thomas the trip
the train there it is yeah that gives
you a better view of it and I you want
to pitch this I love how you use it
absolutely and actually it runs on a
Lionel train track oh it does so it's
it's legitimate I think there might be a
video I might have uh I might have put
that one out a little later oh no there
he goes
oh it has no sound
it might be for the best yeah but okay
so it runs on a track that is that is
spectacular and is this one lighting up
any Runway soon I guess it's it's
lighting up the damn Railway
and this is never before used this is
never before used all my units never
before used I mean some you know some
are like slightly used like it'll be
used yeah I like big league in the
industry that's what we usually do like
apparently unit it's fair game so so
this is fantastic we love to see it you
guys uh do you have any of those iconic
ones on Tick Tock they all get removed
right oh my gosh yeah I've been deleted
off Tick Tock oh
heck yeah this is another spectacular
spectacular unit whoa oh yeah that's the
oops all stuff it's the all-stuff yeah
like at the factory you know they're
gonna screw up every now and then it
happens
they just laid on way too much stuff oh
man that is so funny too much cream
I mean holy [__] everybody loves the
double though oh you have the devil
stuff yeah Green between have you ever
had a cream between
no I never had that one yeah but you got
kids but he wants to
I've had an Oreo thank you yeah yeah I
prefer cream between to be honest
so um are you ever gonna put on like a a
like a gallery yeah Gallery I hear you
yeah I think I don't know I think like
the demand is out there uh-huh but I
want people to show up
I'll show up you'll show up oh yeah okay
I'm gonna Mark your words I said maybe
I only say maybe I just hedge it a
little bit because I
usually find an excuse not to go to
things I hear you honestly like it's in
the way though but we could we could
promote it on the show oh that would be
incredible because I I genuinely love
your art thank you and it is Art yes I
appreciate you 100 I really am curious
about how you make this stuff um that
that's gonna be a trades there's no way
you are definitely handsome because
there's too many people out here trying
to uh
be me
let's see what else the Supreme oh yeah
that's that is
the Supreme one it's here
yo we get to see that this The Scrub
Daddy this one oh my God
I love that not the collab I expected
oh yo
no that one has never been painted wait
wait okay this is so crazy it has the
Louis Vuitton yeah like
you guys gotta see it close up of this
this is crazy and then you can it's
sealed at the at the tip yeah right so
it's like it's guaranteed never been
used but so if if I if I were to buy
this from you right and I wanted to test
drive it how would I puncture that see
they thought of that they they already
thought of that they were like okay
there's no resale value if somebody can
use this right
and so we just make it unusable okay and
then everybody you know all the heads
are happy dude I cannot believe it
that was tough that was actually really
good thank you for noticing that
immediately I know this is it it's so
good I feel pretty good
it feels legit [__] it okay oh yeah it
feels good feels right here the
um the Louie the Baton on that unit
Scrub Daddy uh shout out to Scrub Daddy
I really would love to work with them
obviously in some sort of different um
Avenue is that one here that one is not
here okay so the Scrub Daddy so which is
the preferred entry point
no you know that's all it's up to you
depends on size yeah it depends on size
depends on sort of stamina
you know you're gonna go through an eye
that that Scrub Daddy clean [__] oh yeah
anything like have you ever been to
somebody's house and they have like the
most tore up Scrub Daddy you've ever
seen I've seen that man it's honestly
disgusting
um I mean I have definitely been one of
those people at one point or another so
here I've got a video
uh one of my faves
oh here's a minion one I'm trying to
find one of the ones I found on Tick
Tock originally the way the way I found
you is just by chance like and they're
all from different accounts I saw it
like three times of you introducing a
different yes and and I don't know I was
like I don't know who he is I don't know
where to find him I know that I love him
I like that it's out there but like I
don't know it is interesting that there
are people that like have whole accounts
dedicated and they say like in in their
little like bio they're like I'm in the
real deal anybody else is a faker what
yeah some even like call me out and like
aim Lazar is a total Faker No I'm the
guy what yeah why why would you go so
out of your way like this look at this
angle I mean that is artistry my friends
that that is artistry that that oh my
God yeah pull his little eyeball out and
then talk about like [__]
talk about multi-use yeah
gee whiz are there all the all the audio
is gone oh yeah so this one I tried to
speak in Minion and I spent weeks
learning the language
it's a mix of Portuguese and French
the green shoes
oh is this is this a [__] no this is
actually
um a concept that I'm sort of pushing
okay
[Music]
um
I want to get in touch with Pleasers
they make uh the stripper heals
stripper heels yeah so you need oh it's
a six inch heel oh [__] in order to add
yeah
I was I was just rolling with the
punches there wait hold on
what happened
oh it's okay that wasn't shown
so this one I caught this one is awesome
you got out the cookies I have a
question for you about this but yeah
here check this out cookies
original
and those man how do you capture the
likeness of those melted chips yes oh
phenomenal I couldn't tell you yeah but
I'm really happy with the way it came
out to be honest they do look quite
melty down here on historic Melrose
Avenue in Sunny Los Angeles California
we're here at the cookie store today
it's a fabulous store
those cookies employees like actually
didn't really like me all right so here
here he is his own unique display in the
store yeah whoa
yeah he's for you
these freaking chocolate chips
I mean those will melt in your hand and
your mouth
gee whiz and you know what this is a
soft cookie this ain't no freaking break
your tooth cookie all right I don't like
those crumbly kind
yeah I mean here it is
incredible unit here for a limited time
only
I love the display case that thank you
Thomas I'm assuming that cookies is a
real place cookies is a real place yeah
then did you just like gorilla this
machine in there pretty much oh my God
you know but they do have high security
at these places
I've been to cookies that's you have to
like wait in a line yeah how did you
carry that machine in well honestly I
waited outside for quite some time
a sort of route in but like I'll tell
you what those employees were not happy
with me I see
this this is Rusty from the Cars
franchise and uh I'm a huge fan of Rusty
uh he's a very memorable character and
he's got a lot of personality so it's
nice to see him end it you're in the
Malik Multiverse absolutely I recently
made him into a monster truck oh did you
yeah can I know those like Tick Tock
videos where they race like the cars on
a treadmill yes yes I put together a
little race
um the Mater Bader did not win though
um let me see here is that this is on
your Instagram page by the way if you
guys want to follow the real Malik
follow him on M
l a z i all right all right
m-l-a-z-r-i we'll put a link in the
description yeah yeah it's just Market
all of his socials are in the
description
what's up with that chair oh wow
this thing yeah
um you got massagers on there yeah I
wish it's mine it's my never-ending
nightmare as well it's his spawn chain
we bought it for a joke and now he's
been in it for years and uh he's stuck
in this horrible City you must like it
Excalibur this is phenomenal oh thank
you oh there's real There's real gravel
in there is that right yeah real gravel
in there for texture yeah
holy smoke man wow and then uh there's
just so many you're just honestly
prolific oh I think so you took the
peanut butter out okay yeah you guessed
it Buster yeah
that smear looks so real how do you do
it yeah I don't know you guys want to
know so here's the Jiffy the top is
original oh
what up Shredder this is the top this is
the Jiffy top that is the Jiffy top and
you know choosy moms do choose Jiff
y cream
but the choosier moms Juiced it this is
never before used oh my God look at that
wow dude that looks insane you can see
where somebody got like a little Hasty
and ripped that so real rip the seal off
yeah I didn't get a clean rip on there
such an attention yeah no on the uh down
the edges there like it's so authentic
the safety seal you know they were they
were itching for it they couldn't wait
so this has been used
that uh no that has not been used okay
it's just for this is just for Vibes
yeah yeah you guys got to show a
close-up I I cannot believe how
realistic this looks and there is a guy
on Twitter on Tick Tock we've talked to
who actually would be a good candidate
for that oh right yeah so he actually is
like he's actually um he's freaking
those jars yeah okay he's also like a
sex offender oh hopefully just extremely
not cool whoa I should say I think I
think that was on Earth allegedly
allegedly yeah stuff were brought up
thing we heard things about things look
at that oh my goodness
show me what other ones got in there
okay we got the Jiffy we got the Supreme
I brought like a nice throwback joint oh
my God
hmm
oh my God
so you have the um the heel yeah so
we're doing a bit of a stiletto yes and
we got the little piggies it's a small
kitten heel
oh this one's a little tighter that one
is tighter I think that's an earlier
model interesting that's a tight fit but
what do you think about the french tips
it's really nice yeah professionally
manicured yeah did you do the manicure I
did the manicure myself I did
I think that's what Cinderella would
have would have had oh is that the
Cinderella shoe that's the Cinderella so
it's called the Blasted slipper yeah
right as you can see and um
it's kind of like the ugly stepsister
though because like she's busting out I
see that remember what you're trying it
on to busting out of it right okay yes
so Cinderella's ugly
stepsisters yeah
forced into the slippery oh God you
you oh my God
pretty slept on unit so here we have
um a ball a a container of tennis balls
yeah brand new looks like it's never
been cracked open yeah so let's go ahead
and take a look
oh wow unfortunately I robbed you of
like the most satisfying part which is
like popping that can no I get it but
and getting that whiff
nothing better nothing beats it honestly
are you sure you never use these oh
promise
but I can't I can't attest to who has
would you would you would you um attest
to that under oath oh yeah absolutely
you got a Bible
no she's ready to go
okay for the athletes of the world yes
you can actually pull that one out about
that yeah I don't want to damage her no
you're good okay so this comes out like
this comes apart no no no no no all
three one unit there you go okay yeah so
here you go
and you can see the little hairs on
there yes I make sure yeah he's got the
perfect hairs on there Wow have you oh
my God you're going to Bob ball yeah
have you thought about taking this to
like the French Open and setting up a
booth potentially
I need a dope manufacturer but uh I'm
not against it there that is wow big fan
those little hairs that's crazy okay and
then I think I might have the best for
last okay oh The Best For Last what
could top what we've already seen my
goodness yeah
this one's wrapped up oh wow
oh the samurai sword look at this one
the KFC it's a KFC bag yeah let's go
wow so what do they call it when they
have those bowls is this like mounted
off to the Bowl do we take it off it's
like I mean but you're gonna put in your
own cream grape so we take it out
[Laughter]
uh Sam is down here why does it smell
like that
I guess the better question is why did I
smell it yeah yes oh no
wait why do I feel like a sandwich
is so rare oh yeah
he's an F boy you can tell
so that is so you would you would create
your own gravy potentially for dipping
absolutely on the side yeah or I don't
know you put a little Lube in there
consider that gravy that's the type of
gravy any sauce could be a gravy any
sauce could be honestly yeah if you are
open-minded enough but not any sauce
could be a Lube to be honest
that's yeah yeah except that a lot of
socks will like dry pretty quick okay
this is the broken arm one
yeah oh man as a kid I broke my arm
quite a bit
yeah please
and then we have the apple pie I mean
you really are prolific oh my gosh thank
you I'm kind of just getting started
here
I got some uh
some moving sort of things to take care
of but once I get going oh wait Vice did
well rest in peace Vice don't even exist
anymore yeah what happened with that I
don't know they just don't have what it
takes they're not made for the new world
I mean we're taking this is the New
Media Company yeah yeah this is
incredible yep
um I'm just looking at this tennis ball
one this is amazing okay
wow
elastomon oh no
she's stacked come on yeah
she's stacked I mean within the Pixar
Universe like that's like kind of a
cream as a crop I mean oh my God and so
there's an insertion hole on this bottom
side yes oh I'm not sure if you want to
scroll through but oh that I can scroll
through yeah with caution
God
dude that is something man so the thing
is she's stuck she got stuck in there
you know what I mean look at that shot
that's so good
she kind of sat in there and then she
she kind of probably but whatever
we could probably whatever that's not oh
this is the one I was talking about
thinking about oh Lumiere oh there's a
funny story about the lair actually yeah
so this is the guy from Beauty and the
Beast oh you're right oh yeah you got me
oh my God yeah man he was the one that
famously lit up the runway oh absolutely
and it had the lights turn on budding
Beauty
funny story about Lumiere is I actually
um
I put him in a safe and I locked him
away all right yeah I thought I'd make
you my guest and Light Up The Runway
with something for my Personal
Collection
as I know this is the only one in
existence
this is the extremely rare lumair Major
D
first one ever put out I mean this
thing's a relic but it's in amazing
condition you never see these I mean
come on this pre-dates flashlights it's
a good old-fashioned Candlelight baby
yeah and it's a beautiful antique but
guess what stop [__] lights
unbelievable
our arms articulate you know for however
you want to say however you want to get
it however you want to light it up
I was doing like a little Andrew Dice
Clay on this one yeah I am this is one
of the best videos ever thank you I love
the way you hyped them as well what was
the story you were going to tell us
about oh about Lou mayor uh so I lived
in a church for like a year during covid
it was awesome it was like no longer an
active church but
um just a beautiful place and uh when I
had to leave I found a safe
um underneath my closet like a floor
safe
and I just locked him in there
and I just I turned the dial I didn't
know the the combo because at that time
there was these Tick Tock videos of
people like finding State yeah he's
still in there people finding safes
right and then they would they would
take you on this series of like eight
videos getting you yeah I remember
opening the same there's never anything
in there but this time oh yeah this time
there is and like my Hope was that
somebody would make one of those videos
that's gonna be crazy someday 100 years
from now yeah can we maybe would it be
not wise to give a clue to where it is
oh right so that somebody can crack that
safe well I mean honestly that that
place was demolished so I gotta believe
that somebody tried and they just
weren't The Tick Tock type oh no yeah
which is unfortunate
[Applause]
not two
oh that's a that's a good oh no that
would be but a goodie right there
the scream canister what what is this
supposed to be remember Monsters Inc oh
yeah oh it's like a little green
canister yeah yeah nice the 23-19 but
that one I was kind of like
doing some crazy stuff like there's a
Lube like uh dispenser within that one
like I'm innovating as well yeah they
need to hit me up because everything you
do is innovation thank you Bug's Life
now let me let me ask you some questions
I'm pretty sure that these units bought
original
they're not that cheap right no no
absolutely and so this seems like an
expensive uh undertaking all this oh
yeah absolutely so what what do you do
you have a day job how are we funding
this yeah I am a production designer by
day I am a production designer I work on
like uh television that's movie that's
perfect
I love building props oh man that's
perfect my favorite is when somebody
comes to me and is like hey we have no
idea who to ask
to build this yeah yeah it's not in the
dark like right now I'm building a
a real-life Taxidermy possum I'm turning
them into a marionette no that is wild
you know wow okay so that explains why
you're so good yeah oh my God thank you
it's amazing I guess I pride myself on
just being good at like just the most
Niche weird things like I'm always
trying to pick up a better skill the way
you can manipulate materials I have no
idea how you do it but it's amazing this
is exciting in Japan they've announced
uh huge collab dude when they did this I
was so stoked on this yeah that's
exciting look at the graphic design
it's incredible I want to make some
trading cards like this
um look how pimp they are okay we have a
Chia Pet that one's real terracotta oh
yeah yeah that really grew on there
that's that I grew that awesome yeah it
took it didn't take that long either it
was like three four days I couldn't
believe it chia's work yeah
oh the American pie apple pie we love
that you can put that one in well
actually
put in the oven you were gonna say yeah
the oven but not the microwave because
of the Tin Pan right yeah just some bite
just heat it up a little bit in the oven
just a little bit because the heat is
important we saw these yeah look what
they did on those toes wait that was
crazy let me go back
like what oh my god oh that's crazy
whoever did that and then oh wow that's
a functional lamp that is a functional
lamp
oh the silicone glows in the dark so
even when you uh that's you shut it off
holy smoke you know I was a real Ode to
Pixar to the Pixar organization wow oh
man that's a deep cut do you work for an
organization or yourself no no I'm I'm
completely freelance okay that's the way
you have trouble finding work or is
there a lot of people lined up to work
for you no I mean honestly I think with
anybody who's freelance it's sort of
just like you take what you can get and
then uh you know you do some things for
free and then might lead to some other
things you know so I don't know one day
at a time
but I got some work right now so that's
that's cool excellent we always I mean
here in L.A I feel like I know I was
looking at y'all's prop Department love
to have a little bunch of weird [__]
made so I think that I would love to
work with you you're so talented yes
well thank you so you know how to uh
repair a door oh easily this guy yeah
easily I got my tools in the trunk I'll
Stick Around yeah we got into uh the
horror we got into a bad habit of
breaking we may have kicked in three
doors I know the bathroom door was
broken
nobody walked in can we get a um
handheld and I'd like to get your
appraisal of the door oh maybe you can
give us a quote oh absolutely because we
got quotes from some other handyman oh I
can't wait to hear okay we're gonna say
no they're freaking trying to rob you
blind
um
hunger FF I can't show this on screen
but I want to show you friends of the
show is this guy hunger FF FF stands for
fist [__] and he is the Premier
um
he is the Premier prolapser in the adult
industry and he just put out a
a toy
of his and as his prolapse and here it
is we can't show it this is the small
one by the way
you're kidding me no that's real yeah
yeah yeah it looks like an earthworm
yeah I don't like that no I'm good
that's the small one we have even a
bigger one you're kidding is that a live
cast so apparently it was difficult it's
a mix
yeah because it's like sort of squirming
around like a 3D imagery oh yeah you
know like bullet time I think they did
like that so what is he doing with this
prolapse
uh he just stopped do you want to see a
video no absolutely not please no like
when I was a kid like I was not into
that stuff like people always show you
like oh it's the blue waffles like no
dude that's gonna be surprising based on
your your art collection yeah true I'm
pretty vanilla though I keep it kind of
a board I don't curse is that right yeah
but I'm yeah thank you it's been a
journey at all Texans better Journey
um so so can I there's no way I can talk
you into watching this clip okay like
two seconds because we we have a
tradition that was quick well let me
explain we have a tradition of showing
our guests this clip okay and this man
this guy hungry he really is a friend of
the show he needs a really nice guy
great and he's just the best at what he
does and so uh I don't feel like a lot
of people do what he does no yeah yeah
but I'll tell you what he he's actually
independent he's become quite wealthy
I'm pretty sure he's a millionaire whoa
because he's just so good at this niche
that he's got he says he's like famous
when he goes to these conventions and
stuff like he gets mobbed yeah because
he's the only one that's pimp all right
I'd like to meet him yeah so um can we
can we pull up the uh the special
Montage yeah
yeah so um
we show our guests this and just to get
their kind of raw reaction on camera
I'll pull it up in a sec I'll give you a
warning okay please yeah I'll let you
know before
it's not for the faint of heart I've
seen it so many times
damn I'm with you I don't know about
this but for me to me it's it's quite um
captivating because I've just never seen
anything like it the first time I saw it
I was like you're like seeing a color
that doesn't exist yeah I just I feel
like that would be like beautiful and
bring it like a tear to your eye it's
definitely gonna bring a theater right
yeah it's kind of did you see that movie
Event Horizon yeah warp into it yeah
it's not like what about football have
you seen existence
probably the best comparison you could
make
okay so um where are we set up for the
door appraisal oh we are yeah go over
there with a b and um I'll watch from
here if you could just appraise the door
give me your thoughts maybe a quote
three doors yeah there's three doors
they're all the same and broken
basically to the same degree am I gonna
be able to hear him from in here
let's see
yeah
okay
I can hear him I mean we're gonna need a
whole new door yeah you can't just
really I mean I would glue this together
but it's not what you want yeah we're
gonna need it then
oh yeah we need a new lock mechanism I
love he's drinking a Bud Light the kids
might still might still be intact
actually yeah the handle can work well
mechanism that's probably around you
about 15 yeah
uh-huh actually there was never a screw
in there he's got tape on his belt
that's probably 15 cents
um door
I'd say a hundred labor let's say a
hundred hundred yeah you're higher bro
you're higher we already got the doors
2 25 15 out the door wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait we have the doors do
you want to fix them now
oh we need a new door though we have it
we haven't we haven't we have we have
some doors actually I'll pay you I'm
gonna pay you know what I'm gonna pay
you and then you can check in on me I'm
gonna pay you 250 per door I'm gonna pay
you 250 per door in labor sounds good
all right yeah can you hear me
you can no yo we got this is on so we
were looking for a door repairman Malik
just walked into our lives
so Mal come back here let's talk
business
it's very exciting
why is AB fitted that's true
why is
I was wondering if there's a segment or
something
baby why are you in a
are you wearing a tie
what is it why are you wearing a tie
oh I don't know I just
I usually dress Are you seriously coming
in here trying to be like Jim right now
like give it a [__] break dude oh my
God that's right Malik let's talk let's
talk about business yeah absolutely how
did it not cross my mind so we have we
have three doors right you live that
needs to be repaired yes okay all
basically the same amount of damage yeah
we have the doors themselves right
perfect is that right all of them I
don't know if they're can you guys ask
Jeremiah there's three there's three
there's two down and there's one up here
are all the doors in the same size in
the studio
I think they're the same size I'm not
100 but if you want to just fix that one
so we could check on you yeah I'm you
just cracked the new beer yeah did you
want one no no impressed wait are you
guys making pre-workout no it's Gamers
it's um it's a it's a nice it's a nice
energetic drink
you want yeah you want to try one I
really like your like custom shakers I
actually haven't tried it yet so this is
a brand new one if you wanna
um yeah that's gamer sub Nation rise up
I haven't drank from it yet rise up and
just say you like it even if you don't
yeah it is good that's good stuff it is
it's caffeinated Amber Subs Nation
it's caffeinated and it's hydrating it's
very hydrating
yeah Gamer's not Nation
um so I'll pay you you said 100 for
labor I'll pay you 250 per door let's go
okay love to do it love to see it and
this is hopefully the beginning of our
beautiful yeah
beautiful long relationship yeah oh
incredible
um basically then let's we'll show you
the prolapse and we'll put you right to
work
absolutely
are we ready with that
okay so obviously I'm gonna open it now
Ian
all right Malik I'm about to open it
okay the first screen is it gonna be on
uh this one here and it's the first
moment is not it's just is it coveted
related
this part's fine this part's nothing oh
okay yeah oh my God
dude what oh I you know I even have to
admit I never looked beyond like you
never loved the first second so I still
haven't seen this yeah I still haven't
really is there Jello oh my God yeah
there's Lube what the day you got a Lube
to get in there man this this can't be
healthy well so that was one of my
questions for him in apparently
his his uh intestines and stuff are in
good condition how do you feel about
this you're you're fine no I mean no
this is not the first time I've seen oh
yeah okay I was I was absolutely
okay that's the part that I've never
seen before yeah so at this moment
answers their question what they're
doing with them but at this moment
they're going prolapse to prolapse and
when I say
you know it's like a color I've never
seen before I mean that I've never
imagined anything like this ever
happening
it feels very Cronenberg yeah yeah you
were right about this this is so awesome
there's our boy that's hunger there on
the uh so is he enjoying this yeah yeah
oh he loves it he loves it okay no he
loves it you know what honestly this is
kind of like a um being double jointed
or something it is no you're right
because he can prolapse on command on
command yeah oh incredible it is like
that we actually had him prolapse um we
had Howie Mandel on and he prolapsed for
him live wow yeah no he's you ever asked
Howie Mandel about Bobby's World
I haven't it's a great show yeah I love
that joke Bobby's World oh I've never
seen it oh yeah so good it was one of
the best cartoons uh it's so good I'd
love to know Howie Mandel's a great guy
he was a part of it yeah I think he
wrote it that was history yeah
so at any rate um that's so this is
Malik
um how do I say your last name lazri
lazri Malik what kind of name is Malik
I've never met him out uh my dad's from
North Africa okay Algeria cool Malik
lazari and do you does your dad live in
Texas as well yeah he lives in San
Antonio
and I Remember the Alamo are you born in
Brad Texas no I was actually born here
in uh uh Santa Monica oh yeah so you're
phony Cedar style never tells people in
Texas you were born in Santa Monica I
don't know I'm kind of Best of Both
Worlds like people here they're like hey
you from here yeah you look apart I sure
am buddy so if you guys want to follow
Malik once again the real Malik the
Link's in the description but on
Instagram that seems to be your main
yeah because I mean Tick-Tock that's
just so unreal yeah
yeah so follow him it's
m-l-a-z-r-i-m lazzary yeah all right so
on this point
um well I'll let you go start working on
the door yes and um we'll follow the
progress as it's happening
sure um maybe do you want to go uh help
him get set up we'll just saw that we'll
just continually cut a little bit as
it's happening but and uh and Ethan we
got to do our uh advertisement right
right our sponsor reads I wanted a
little I understand distance maybe we
can do um
oh I know what we could do
if you if you look uh right under Lego
rejected or oh yeah Okay so yesterday
was Ian's birthday yes and I was trying
to play it cool but we actually do have
a present for Ian
um that we're gonna present today so Ian
what's what what's the age
guess
look at uh 28.
that's close 29 thank you 29. thank you
I just want to say that I realized that
I coined a new thing I I left a comment
on Ian's Instagram and I was like this
is kind of Genius so I need to let
everybody know I called him Ian Slater
[Applause]
that is badass I agree with that I think
we should all adopt it you're welcome
all right so go go ahead and rip that
bad boy open Ian
slay Queen happy 29th birthday of course
and uh this is a custom oh yep Sam are
you around
I know I've been looking for her this
whole second man go ahead show it off
okay
[Music]
okay it's not a Sharky's gift card to
the people guessing in chat we've got
pillow protector
those are stain proof of mattress
protector yeah these are stained proof
high quality Goods hypoallergenic too
really nice so when it's to protect you
and your your property and your bed yes
from the terrorism of Sam's nighttime
eating habits we yep we had a dinner in
bed last night
on board
what'd you guys eat
we had uh some borders all burgers in
bed Burger in bed Burger in bed
and french fries in bed
uh yeah we went with the tots we we're
living large it's taught time baby
birthday top day birthday talks for sure
and uh what did you guys watch
uh Sam was showing me her Tick Tock
faves okay that's great that's a good
evening right there nice
that's a good old time right there I'll
tell you what brother yeah but this is
gonna come in handy thank you guys I
hope you can actually put that to use
for real oh I will like within the next
few hours those are stain proof and
waterproof we actually have those on our
masters because
we don't have it on the pillows but but
I figured Ian is gonna need it I like to
protect the matches because you never
know the mattress yes and it's like the
mattresses are so expensive
than getting a new one is such a
disaster you got you got to protect it
you know what I mean yeah no that's it's
good happy birthday buddy thank you so
much thank you
uh can we cut to what's going on there
with Malik I hear the con this
uh
we can't right now no I hear the sounds
of construction let's thank our sponsors
yeah I have to give a big shout out and
a thank you
to hexclad
this is such a cool sponsor
I am such a fan of their products
I have been using straight up hex clad
pans and knives actually their knives
are really good too and cutting boards
for close to a year yeah and these pans
are
insane
now I know you got you might look at the
price and be like oh that's a little
expensive you know it's like here's 200
for a 12 inch good pans good stainless
steel pans that's what they cost
but what you get with this
is insane I there's not a single blemish
on this pan and I've I cook everything
in it
it's non-stick
high performance
it doesn't have any um TEF or what is
what do they call that [__] they put on
Teflon yeah they don't have any
chemicals or Teflon it's just their
genius design
that keeps the pan it keeps it non-stick
keeps it hot it distributes the heat I
mean this is the best pan I've ever used
all different flavors dishwasher safe
oven safe induction ready how is that
possible it's on induction and fire yeah
I don't I was curious about that too
yeah I I I cannot speak high enough on
their products um
they have pan sets this is what I got
the uh let's see we have like a whole
set yeah we got the set I think it must
have been
probably that one on the top left I
think yo a lot of love for hexclad in
the chat dude oh okay this is such an
amazing brand and I'm so grateful that
they're uh sponsoring us they're
actually fans and the story of how we
hooked up is really cool yeah but the
point is is that their their family and
their products are amazing and if you
guys are in the market for new pans I'd
love if you would check them out
um
um yeah their pans are amazing I'm glad
that the fupa Troopers like it their
knives are sick too they have this
cutting or it's a knife board it's
magnetic it's so
um
so convenient it's so satisfying to put
them up on the magnet isn't it I love it
so I have I have this set we never
actually had a set of nice knives before
so and they're really nice it's so nice
like not having them in the drawer yeah
you could see them yeah I recommend I
recommend the pans and then if you have
a little bit of extra guacamole I try
the knives but the pans is where it's at
with them
um
it's fantastic it's going to change it
all up for you if you like cooking at
home
it's all about hexclad and I'll tell you
what
something else for you guys
uh if you go to hexclad.com after dark
which is in the description you get 10
off
right
no it's just use code after dark no 10
off okay let me try that again try again
get 10 off with the promo code after
dark there it is right and here in the
link is hexclad.com after dark and uh I
yeah I'm I there I mean come on you
can't get a better sponsor come on you
can you just cannot
except perhaps
our other sponsors just as good which is
just as good it's as good as it gets
yeah so that's the only exception though
I I can give you my personal uh stamp of
approval on Hex Cloud give it a try
thank you to them
thank you to you guys
uh and then next up we have native thank
you to Native for sponsoring us we love
our sponsors and Native
makes
such a fantastic product it smells
amazing it's all natural there's none of
that crazy weird sunscreen chemicals
that Kilt destroys reefs
um
there's been so much controversy around
sunscreen right pretty incredible smell
that
it's coconuts and Barbados no it's
coconuts and pineapple
I like it it's subtle which I like it's
subtle it's nice mineral face lotion
it's also
moisturizing but uh Native has a ton of
amazing products deodorant I've been
using the deodorant it's so nice I mean
here let me tell you a little about it I
love the feeling soaking up the sun this
time of year it's coming up Summer
but with all the time in the sun I I
frankly am very worried about wearing
sunscreen sunscreen you have to do it on
you on screen gang as well I you have to
do it big time and I'm really um I fry
in this one I don't let the kids go in
the song without I'm really yeah
it's so important yeah but with Native
sunscreen you can get the skin
protection you need and also soak up
those rays
natives quickly absorbing Ultra share
hydrating and lightweight sunscreen
formula offers broad spectrum SPF 30
protection from UVA and UVB rays all
Native sunscreen is made with a 20
active zinc oxide formula that
dermatologist tested and suitable for
sensitive skin all skin types
all Native sunscreen is made with oils
derived from plants that seal in skin
moisture it's vegan and cruelty free all
different flavors don't eat it
I made that clear last time
choose from one of native's three
delicious but subtle scents like
coconuts pineapples Rose Sweet Peach and
nectar
okay okay for face or body or they have
an unscented option too for my sensitive
kings and queens
yeah uh you use their shampoo babies I
use a deodorant yeah the deodorant the
shampoo is really good too I used that
once before I haven't tried it they're
whole they're whole
lineup I use the shampoo it's fantastic
right and this is a man who cares about
his hair I mean look at this beautiful
flowers
look at them baby native you think Zach
would put anything less than the best in
his hair stop it
give your uh let's see with Native
sunscreen you get protection from the
Sun that is free of chemical additives
like oxybenzone
benzone which makes native sunscreen
compliant with the Hawaii act 104 which
was passed in an effort to protect
Hawaiian reefs give your skin the
protection it deserves with hot natural
natives
mineral sunscreen go to Native Deo do
nativedeo.com after dark or use the
promo code after dark at checkout get 20
off your first order that's
nativedeo.com after darker using promo
code after dark at checkout links in the
description
nativedeo.com after dark or use promo
code after dark we love them
boom I have an announcement uh
a second plane is just hit the tower
boom
so the door we got is the wrong size
a b was was uh giving me the option to
um uh still go through with the bet
but but unfortunately the door doesn't
fit okay and I I was like well if it's
not gonna open and close at the end then
I don't we don't have that Triumph a
moment yeah yeah okay Alex not gonna get
and there it is guys and there it is
there's the bathroom where's the live
that's a live uh
direct from the bathroom is Malik just
roaming free you've got to keep an eye
on a guy like that
I trust him he seems like a trustworthy
guy I'm just kidding I mean he doesn't
curse oh he's in there taking
measurements
[Laughter]
there he is can we get some like men
working music for this Zach this is out
like some real [__] like we got real
men breaking doors and real men fixing
doors oh
when's the last time Adam preached here
we go in one episode
losers look at him man that's a real man
in action
bust out that tape boy yeah that's a
real man in action right there okay oh
he's measuring that one
a beer another beer Men At Work
yeah buddy
Whispering the beer
there it is when you're a real man you
measure it
goddamn near everything needs to be
thank you Malik
but uh
[Applause]
right we might want to turn that off
before uh
I do genuinely want to hire him to fix
them yeah yeah let's do it maybe the bit
today doesn't work but we can film it
and Monday
it'd be fun
okay guys please yeah
you know
very handy yeah
how long did we wait to do the sponsors
uh about an hour okay we've done worse
been worse I think it's fine back in the
day man we used to do like because we
only did one episode a week so we would
have like four sometimes five sometimes
six I don't think we ever did six five I
think five was good absolutely our ad
read for like 20 minutes long which was
horrible for everybody yeah
and also I mean with peace and love you
were you have become much better at
addream all the time like every time
pretty much start over a minute ten
minutes I remember for one act yeah and
you have four more yeah no you you have
become far better at doing those thank
you well at least I'm better at
something yeah
but um we sometimes would like not even
do them because we get lost in the sauce
for like two hours until like a three
hour show two and a half hour show
horrible but yeah we love them please
support our sponsors they really are
amazing well at this point in the show
uh we've all been waiting patiently
uh for
oh we have we already have questions to
chat is Malik single y'all are thirsty
I'm gonna do a bathroom break while we
get set up okay make sure you use the
right one
because I think he's in the left one and
I disconnected the
uh oh I don't want you to walk in on
them well that too I guess
a good point
oh he left already yeah he he bounced
he's a good man I love that guy he's so
funny
he genuinely
I genuinely believe that he is like
a brilliant artist a million percent oh
yeah yeah no doubt like it's so unique
and it's so how frequently do you see
like legit art that's so funny right and
this is Art his craftsmanship is insane
yeah it's really really high quality
every one of them is unique in like all
the little details and everything and
then like the [__] cherry on top is
that his presentation like he's just so
[__] funny and his way of like
selling it is hilarious so yeah he rules
that's awesome he's in La hopefully we
can uh continue to cross paths yeah
maybe we can get who's got the next
birthday maybe we can get a custom
flashy
um how about a oh I've got an idea
a berserk Fleshlight for Dan God no
that's horrific well it's your favorite
anime isn't it I mean sure but
cuts his eye hole Yeah his eye hole
Brave Style
Dan Crenshaw flashlight yeah no I
understood I understood the reference
yeah so at any rate um
Olivia Olivia I'll wait for ELA actually
I know she's interested she needs to
hear this but yeah we are I'm queuing up
of course the PowerPoint Grace Van Deen
and today's rain yes
now I went into this conflict I don't
know all the twists and turns okay so
I'm actually I spoke with love
beforehand he's gonna pop in
every now and then to talk about phase
lore because they're just a bunch of
pockets that like maybe he knows better
than I do yeah love is a phasologist
he's a physiologist and and I know that
this is between uh the two individuals
but I feel like the organization needs a
little bit of representation so I'll be
adamantly defending phase or face blanks
uh I don't really have a dog in the
fight between the two individuals
involved but I just want to make sure
the good name okay is not solid you
actually are represented in the
PowerPoint okay good good good good good
so your solidarity I went into this with
preconceived notions frankly and what's
interesting about this dispute is there
seems to be
a strong divide between the grace
supporters and the phase Reign
supporters now what I've seen
at least what I've seen
is that phase rain is being a giant
douche to her
and it seemed like he was all in the
wrong but I'm feeling that there's more
to the story
so I went in very similar to the way you
feel I still think that like some of the
[__] he said that will watch is like why
the [__] would anyone do that ever there
were reasons that I didn't know about
as to why he didn't want her to join so
we will talk about it I'm very excited
let's get started yila's back
again PowerPoint time
oh damn girl that looks [__] good you
want a cookie I want to get hamburgers
in bed now that I me too actually are
hamburgers in berserk yes
[Applause]
are you watching berserk too we just
started last night oh awesome I love it
there's one I'm so excited when we find
a show that we both love it's so fun
I had watched the other series but I
hadn't seen the old one which apparently
is the good one I'm loving him I mean it
I remember back then I kept telling you
you gotta watch I couldn't find it yeah
he was looking on all the apps and
eventually it was on YouTube
if you guys want to watch berserk
there's one video
and I am not watching this because that
would be
that would be oh copyright infringement
uh-huh right okay you bought the DVD or
something say it
I can say I can't say it say that it's
out there I guess
just type berserk YouTube right
so you know what to avoid and buy a DVD
yeah I don't think I'll go buy the DVD
like genuinely I don't know what you
probably buy it used I that's how I
originally saw it years ago my my friend
had this series on
[__] was it on VHS
1997. I think I think it was DVD listen
I don't know who owns this IP but they
are [__] up I cannot watch it
anywhere
and I can't even buy the show anywhere
I don't get it yeah you've been watching
it on VHS right yeah yeah I pulled out
the yeah exactly I want to say that I've
been into an anime phase now um I'm kind
of like over the realities for a minute
so we've watched Demon Slayer and I'm
obsessed that one I have to watch I love
it and then we also watched the salmon
saw man was awesome and I love that too
that was a recommendation by chat
chainsaw man chainsaw man
I was very very impressed that's your
rules yeah yeah animation's awesome in
that one yeah yeah I'm super into the
like the story in the world I'm I know
that the SEC the second season's coming
up oh nice beginning of next year I
believe or fall this year I read
um it's it's weird you guys are watching
berserk right now because I just put a
little berserk reference at the end of
the Lego video oh I noticed that yeah
yeah I noticed that
ela's in for a ride though you guys are
excited for the new um sex on the city
season
and just like that are you serious a new
one yeah did they not retire that [__]
yet well they did like a rebounding into
Golden Girls uh yeah I have watched the
I will watch it it's a fantastic show
and apparently Samantha's coming back
this season oh yeah you told me no
Samantha but I just saw them you're not
in the room with them it's a phone call
whispers are saying that Kim didn't even
like see the girls on set okay what is
going on here y'all are Sex in the City
family no I've never seen it I've just
seen it
what's going on what it's a good show
man I'm I'm such a such a Samantha I
mean come on
I know I need to watch it years ago
years ago I was dating a girl that loved
it and would watch it all the time so
like kind of by proxy learned all the
characters and everything I wouldn't say
I watch it and honestly the fashion Ela
is insane like it's you'd love it like
it's so good
it's New York baby what is happening
here so um yeah something is why I'm not
I enjoy the show I believe Zach he's
full of surprises you know what Ela if
you watch it I'll watch it at the same
time as you I will definitely watch it I
watched the last season okay book club
um Bobby Lee was on there
somebody asked um
uh somebody asked I forget I missed it
never mind
whoever you are ask it again
somebody asked something interesting
anyway
all right let's open this PowerPoint
oh someone said ranking of Kings
first season of raking in Kings
incredible yeah
walk in loved it yeah second season I'm
enjoying it's a little bit weird I don't
know why they're doing what they're
doing with the storytelling I just want
a linear story but it's like it's so
hard for me to follow and I don't like
want to show does that to me because
like I shouldn't feel stupid watching
something you know I know I'm capable of
following a story yeah but I'm like not
capable of following this season I don't
know why I think there are reasons to do
it but I think in general people are
doing it way too often with the
non-linear storytelling just to like
make their show seem cool or interesting
and a lot of the times I think you're
right it's just it's just confusing and
annoying
um
there it is all right phase the [__] up
Chrissy Chrissy
Grace Van DM versus
versus all right wait what is happening
like interior out that was me my bad
yeah
all right go ahead are we good yeah okay
Chrissy face up
um our players our first player is Grace
Van Diane she uh is a streamer she makes
content she was also Chrissy on Stranger
Things very exciting next player
that's FaZe Rain he's one of the OG
phase members very good gamer he's one
of the founders yeah so he's probably
stacked he's probably Super Rich then
right right love he's stacked well he
that's one of the things he's mad about
he's oh stack says he should be uh he's
probably loaded right but a little bit
[__] up over according to the internet
it says 3 million
but I would assume as the founder
because they went public that he would
have got a massive payout it depends on
if I mean he left too soon there when
they did that yeah exactly apparently
from what I I I've heard I still think
he owns the stock
oh then he's broke because that stock is
worthless yeah I'm not face down phases
are like straight up pennies pennies
stock you guys the face stock they were
about to get kicked off the NASDAQ has
that happened because uh it had it was
below a dollar and it was if it's over
if it's below a dollar for over a month
or something you get kicked off the
NASDAQ well the good news is they had an
explosive day six percent up three cents
yeah he's in value that's huge I have a
question what is the purpose of somebody
joining phase like what do you get out
of joining this thing it's a gaming
organization so what that means
it used to be real popular like when I
was playing Starcraft
and they would take people who are
really good at the game who didn't have
a lot of means because they're just
young kids who don't have any money at
all and streaming and all this stuff
wasn't like a huge huge industry back
then
so they would pay them like a monthly
salary put them up in a gaming house
where they could train all day and then
send them to all the tournaments and pay
for everything and then they I guess
they get a cut of the winnings or and
they also have sponsors so it's like a
sports team in that sense crazy sponsors
we're talking DC yeah would somebody
like her be interested in that is this
issue like a serious gamer like to
belong to something I imagine and also
she she talks about how like when she
was there it felt like it was family and
okay it sounded like she wanted like the
camaraderie it's The Prestige of it yeah
it's just okay the attention a gardeners
when you join phase I think is uh is
selling point okay a talent agency
oh like Italian yeah it's Talent OR
talent in terms of playing like
streaming and gaming
um the way that FaZe Rain speaks about
it you had things were different when it
started versus now yeah sure yeah yeah
but unfortunately to the stockholders of
phase
not looking too hot and small correction
it was it was because they were below a
dollar for over 30 days they get
they get a warning essentially and after
that they have 180 days to get the stock
up above a dollar and then they get
delisted so I think they are in that
they're somewhere in that 180 day period
right now well so they are still listed
but if they don't get up above a dollar
soon they're going to be taken off the
nest well if they want to do that
they'll have to literally double the
value of their company
well so it was at like twenty dollars a
share like in like August yeah when it
launched and people thought it was
interesting and then they're like wait
what am I buying this is dumb worthless
crap right
um big issue with that um
there's a big face supporter and uh
potential face Prospect call me banks
um I think that they're gonna pull it
off they think they're gonna pull I
think they're gonna pull it out I think
I think I'm gonna phase up buy stock
then put your life saving I am so
overextended on face dog I can't even
tell you
I had I had I had the accountant I mean
my paycheck just goes directly into
their stock love do you own face stock
no I would never buy that [__]
I love Facebook old face when it was
like a gaming organization type thing
now it's like now they're just owned by
a bunch of Boomers who don't know
anything I feel like all right well so
here here's FaZe Rain okay all right our
next player that's FaZe Banks we're not
in the middle my boy
thanks
okay
[Laughter]
all right my seed is all over this place
next player FaZe Clan as a whole I don't
like that they have like gang signs they
throw up
so I just threw Mr Beast in there
because look at him
he's not a member of FaZe
dude they better keep the gang signs
themselves there's certain neighborhoods
you start flashing that [__] you'll
it'll be the last time you phase up
just saying man
so next phase posted on Twitter uh May
18th of this year we want more women in
FaZe Clan as like a little breadcrumb
for what they were going to announce
okay which is fair I mean yeah I think
it's like that's a nice bit of a
publicity thing a bit of a sausage party
over there yeah more female represent
let's go I mean I wouldn't be surprised
if there were zero women there's
sure
there's about 100 women and there's been
a couple over the years all right
but go ahead phase Reign does not like
surprises so he commented underneath
spoiler alert it's Grace and the only
reason I heard was because she's on one
episode of stranger things which
that's me that's mean to Grace like I
understand your your reasoning but like
you're dragging grace through it when
you're publicly but this is crazy
because this is his
business he's not in it anymore yeah
okay he's not it I thought you guys
still had it he he's not part of the
organization okay yeah so he's shooting
on it now
or but he owns stock his loves it wasn't
his choice though oh he's still a member
of FaZe yeah you gotta like run it or
anything I got phase in the name yes but
he has a vested interest in the success
of this company he does he he owns a
bunch of them he's up yeah but he's like
done right he wants the old he he's done
this like Boomers out thing he wants all
the because they got [__] like four
years ago or five years way back they
got [__] at some point where they sold
out to some some manager right and they
pretty much swept the company out of the
original owners or the founders that
means they got paid
they didn't I don't think they'd
properly got compensated for it I think
that is part of the issue that sounds
like he's not a bosses yeah so it's like
there was a huge mess when this
situation started which is what I didn't
know when I started figuring all of this
stuff out there was like a war already
Brewing okay and the ogs and the clan so
my take right here out the gate yeah
this is the first shot this is the first
comment so FaZe Rain is Straight Out The
Gate
being a giant [__] douche and I'll
tell you why
first of all he's minimizing her she's
like oh she's just been in one episode
of stranger things like
what have you done bro you're a [__]
Pro Gamer shut up dude okay and second
of all kind of always being
unprofessional super unprofessional and
again it's not her fault that FaZe
decided to invite her to join right and
I mean it also just reflects badly on
him if this is partly your business I
don't know if it's still in it or not
whatever but this is also his business
and it's like yeah if you go down to
this level
just only speaks badly about him in my
opinion and clearly they didn't bring
her on because she was on one episode of
stranger things correct like come on
dude
also that's a
if that's
with a
[__] Chrissy is amazing Chrissy wake up
yeah stranger things
one of the most famous shows ever she
could have straight up segued into a
massive acting career totally and she
still might all the other people did
yeah so I just think unnecessarily
dragging her name and 100 yeah it's so
mean-spirited for no reason yeah say
something about the org like why are you
saying go after her don't go after her
yeah all right so continuing so FaZe
doesn't like surprises FaZe warns Grace
that she's going to be collateral damage
he said uh don't get barbecued in the
process and she responded to him all
these years in the kitchen have me
prepared so wait when did he he just
direct messaged her he no he tweeted
that out don't get barbecued in the
process because everybody is like
people who care about the phase org and
like the Integrity of the talent and
stuff they're already so pissed and now
that they're because Grace isn't like
she has admitted like she's not a super
great gamer but she does love it which
is like awesome that's the type of
content I like to watch personally so if
FaZe wants to go into that content
farming like part of YouTube That's or
the part of streaming that's their
prerogative and it's it's not Grace's
fault that they want her on board
by the way YouTube is still crashing I
can't [__] believe oh right now you
know I've been whenever I listen that
never happened to me it's a iPhone thing
I think I watch on average you do every
time every it comes in ways where
there's like
we even did a poll it's 50 of people
have experienced these crashings
it has happened to me either but I don't
really I don't really watch my own live
stream because I'm on it well I do right
that wouldn't make a lot of sense if I
was watching it
so but what's the call why did he um
tweet this at her did she never said
anything to him and he's coming at her
again he's coming at her and saying
you he's basically saying you you better
know what you're getting yourself into
so he he continues to go in yes he's
he's provoking her whilst trying to
provoke phase as a whole like he's
always getting so far as loser and
jealous like that's all I'm getting mean
spirited in terms of the words he chose
for sure not very thoughtful no no
straight up bitter loser and so then her
response to being unprovoked attacked is
all these years in the kitchen have me
prepared which is more than a fair
response because it is definitely giving
sexism yeah
girl go home gamer girl yeah
yeah people are asking issues so she is
a gamer for the record yes and and also
we will see the stuff that he says about
her later it's it morphs way more into
sexism than we like you'll see it gets
there are there are more things okay so
uh here we go
so okay so FaZe rain's first video was
pretty polite and he got out like what
he feels about should I watch this yes
okay yeah just the time's down she's a
nice girl I don't know her I've never
seen her streams or I don't even watch
stranger things like that I saw a few
episodes Grace if you're like watching
you just self-reported bro you haven't
watched stranger things [__]
still what an idiot yeah don't you know
11 is crazy
yes sir you've seen my tweets like I
apologize I'm sorry but it's not really
about you or me right now it's kind of
about the bigger picture because I just
don't necessarily believe in these
recruits at all right I could go off and
talk about that for a million different
reasons because just someone's bigger
they're doing their own thing there's a
lot of politics obviously behind the
phase recruits I've been saying that for
a while it's on Twitter that they you
know they posted the announcement
so we we took you through that I just
wanted you to see his first video very
moderately tempered
okay totally fine the next yeah we can
click out of her so the next thing it
says watch him watching Grace he this is
his second video Grace responded to him
um
here you can see me starting with phase
is because FaZe Rain said that the only
reason I was signed with FaZe is because
I was on Stranger Things
um
I'm sorry sir were you in the meeting
with us that's my [__] boy it's like
that is literally my boy you don't need
to call her a [__] yeah what is your
point that you weren't yeah many times I
I really don't like that like there's
just no need man
yeah like you're the owner of an org and
you're acting like this right that's my
no wonder y'all got Fate no wonder
phases in Ruins no wonder being run by
man children no wonder you weren't in
the meeting
true and why would you be there I'm
gonna go back today
I'm sorry sir were you in the meeting
then I was signed with phase go shoot it
go shoot him go look normal so this is
what Grace said about me let's hear it
about me starting with FaZe is because
FaZe Rain said that the only reason I
was signed with FaZe is because I was on
Stranger Things
um
I'm sorry sir were you in the meeting
with us that's my [__] boy
not her fault right take it up with your
the morons that you guys you guys hired
remember you're the founder of FaZe
take it up with them why would you be
get pouring [__] on her it's just so
selfish to drag her career down while
trying to fix whatever the [__] he's
trying to fix also her response was like
so tame yeah yep she's like excuse me
were you in the meeting what could it be
more tame and she says Get Wrecked
that's literally it I can tell this dude
has like never had a close relationship
with a woman no he has a girlfriend okay
take it back immediately
immediate retract you just got wrecked
you just got right just the way you
threw out [__] about talking to a
random girl just gives like
I just hang out with dudes all day long
I mean
he's still not hang out just with dude
stay long
sorry that is very reflective of The
Gaming Community too right like that
kind of [__] flies all the time so and
the the thing here like I'm a big fan
right after seeing this is kind of like
I don't get it why are you going after
her when I get it you're like pissed off
your these people quote unquote ruined
your your organization right why go
after her she's on the same level as you
she's just a member right yep so it
doesn't make any sense like he's ruining
his whole cause of having this Fair
criticism right I'm sure I'm not
entirely exactly sure on what he's
trying to say about that org but you can
talk [__] about these old people ruining
your your thing but why why mess with
her he should have been friends with her
right there's no reason there's actually
no reason yo what's the point of a clan
if we're not all family like love is
saying maybe he actually has a good
point to make I don't really know maybe
yeah but this is like so not the way to
talk about this yeah no he has lots of
moment moments of like oh I hear what
you're like I understand why you're so
angry right now but then he'll make it
about Grace when it's clearly like his
anger is misplaced and it's directed at
the wrong person and it's he's angry at
him fair it's not fair for running his
business into the ground he's up and he
and you know he can't he can't blame
himself because that's too painful if
you click the next link it's a bunch of
cool people deciding who the FaZe fans
want to see in face that's what I'm
getting at it's not people who know what
the community wants it's random Boomers
that are doing it dude she said you told
her you are you are hired basically an
affirmative action hire
and she says were you in the meeting
that's it dude chill the [__] out
okay next yeah click the second link on
that side like he calls her mid
is he talking about her this is a crazy
clip is he talking about her looks yes
this is a crazy this is the one that
ruined it for me you can't really come
back from that that's straight keemstar
that's not yeah
okay this is gonna be painful
so
cheeky and phase world that's sorry uh
as a gamer
saying Get Wrecked is one of the biggest
insults you could give okay let's be
real that's a good answer practically a
slur yeah it's really it's it's worse
than a slur in a way it's like the N
word for gamers
community so they feel like accepted and
he's doing this he's doing this voice
yeah
and give him a space in the community so
they feel like accepted it's a male
dominated industry if we put in women
yeah girl rules shut the [__] up bro
get [__] wrecked
she did not [__] on you boy if you
trying to build this into something of a
beef she literally said get wrecked
anyone with that opinion not even
specifically you get wrecked yeah okay
watch it again good so watch it again
[__] wrecked oh my God I just can't
compete with that man I can't she she
roasted me it's over Grace I'm sorry all
I want to say is your golden Valerie
make stranger things your entire
personality even though you're all on
one episode you found out about twitch
through Tumblr not only have you not hit
a trick shot but you don't even know
what the [__] that is when you were
still playing with Bart I don't even
know what a trick shot is first of all
dude time for a reality check lame he
doesn't even know what the trick shot is
bro you don't even know what the shot is
I don't know by the way I just saw a
really funny comment wrecked with a hard
r
no she hit him with the heart R
uh dude you need a reality check you
literally just said you've never even
hit a trick shot in full sincerity okay
you need to stop right now
I made my first million out of this
industry and on top of it you're
excruciatingly mid who I would never let
touch me on my drunkest night
[Music]
um
um that's a disgusting thing to say
Adam once again she really has he came
at her twice her responses were super
mild probably she probably she I mean
she had no choice everyone in her chat
was probably like yo you can talk about
this she said almost nothing about it
and he came at her in the most [__] up
way ever me
maybe if you are hotter I wouldn't be
pissed this guy needs to go higher yeah
this is like embarrassing yeah for him I
hope he's embarrassed about it he has
unresolved issues like you don't say
that how old is he it's so cringe it's
rain let's find out
this man's like you haven't even done a
1080 no scope 27. that's what he said
he's like you have never done a 1080 no
scope
oh my God oh my God
you're talking about twirling around in
a video game dude he's 27. Jesus Christ
and he wouldn't touch her with a what
what did he says the strongest night
yeah and it's to find God or something
also what the [__] she's so beautiful
like yeah what like what weird weird
choice for a person I'm not even gonna
respond to that because it's just on its
face it's just so absurd insulting to
even bring up anything like that in this
conversation about business you're so
mid and by the way on top of all those
this guy is straight up like
you would you don't deserve to be here
you have barely said anything to me but
I gotta tell you something you're also
ugly yeah
[Music]
cool thing going on
no laughter I hit the button
the button's becoming my joke fell flat
so I need to hit yeah no but it was the
last like three instances I got to be
here for a true button moment that's not
true it was it wasn't even that bad I
just mean like experience I don't have
time to process it if it was like a
little bit on the margin and then we'll
Bowl right back look at the buttons
dude that's awesome the Microsoft I love
all the screens I'm gonna update it on
Monday there's a lot of new ones on the
subway
so talented if you'd like to make your
own feel free to submit it on our
subreddit we have a button flare for
that and uh feel free to add you're like
it was just um it was just exciting for
a moment for me to be here while you do
it you know what because I've been
watching and I see it right it happened
smash that button
you know what my line of sight on the
button is obstructed by all these cups
and actually it's actually yeah that's
true yeah it's a bit of a hazard yeah
keeping this unobstructed and I think I
need to move the drinks out of the way
do you want to try your joke again for
those that missed it no I don't know
it's fine
we can rebuild let's go
first million out of this industry and
on top of it you're excruciatingly mid
to I would never let touch me on my
drunkest night it [__] wrecked all
right
yeah and then he tries to make it be
like yeah look what she said to me again
just so you know how [__] up she is
Get Wrecked [__] yeah completely
unnecessary from him all right so she
fires back okay right she so she says
something in this video besides the one
thing that people have clipped and are
confused about which we're about to
watch most of the stuff she said is
similar to the stuff that we've talked
about why we hate that he said that why
it's not fair that he did that however
this clip people had stuff to say about
it because they were I just wanted to
say like yes this girl is made right
like what are you talking ridiculous
what reality exactly are you living in I
don't know why it's just so sad it's
like this whole thing is such a
self-report you just going off as such a
loser he would say to anybody yes he
would just say to anyone oh and by the
way you're ugly yeah I wouldn't want to
[__] you it's like nobody asked all
right I literally trust me nobody's
going uh the bed sad about that
um how old is she
let me triple check how tall is FaZe
Rain uh
what's his blood type Grace is 26. okay
so they're similarly aged okay just one
year okay here we go says I don't even
know what a trick shot is you're right I
don't oh she shouldn't have admit that
stop but you should not have admit that
a lot of replies on Twitter said the
same thing why would you admit that just
because everybody knows what a trick
shot is like if you were in phase and
you don't know even what it is that you
can't admit that right Dan yeah no I
mean this is a crucial error that she
just did this step you know I was
feeling for her I thought that was
really over the line what he said but
now
so can someone between that and the
gamer word that she said I mean gamer
wait so that was actually fine though
what a trick shot is is that when you're
like using
something like a like a a wait what are
they called like a hack in the game no
no it's so stupid it's like you know on
skateboarding you do like a 1080 swooshy
no scope okay they do that in the game
and then they get the shot and watch
this it is actually like
hilariously I mean it's cool for them
but like it's not that [__]
interesting yo you see that you see that
you spun around he committed to the
ocean look he sees the enemy and he's
like jumped off spins around spins
around heads down boom Oh a trick shot
you just do a lot of Dance Before ready
let me let me demonstrate that's what
that is that's it that's it what it is
you can do cam is actually going to do a
live trick shot for us right now okay
[Music]
[Applause]
can you do it again for me
sprayed Windex oh that's a trick shot
so I mean at the time phase was formed I
guess trick shots was like a cool thing
but it's always been like a meme on the
internet like the MLG stuff you remember
how yeah yeah yeah in those edits yeah
it's all that's all a parody of these
over-the-top silly tricks but that was
like I feel like 10 years ago
this guy really didn't grow up
you're still living in the days of trick
shots yeah it was like a gamer's like
acting role like they would show their
trick shots as like compilations and
they would get a lot of views but I mean
we were parodying it like 10 years ago I
want to show you I've made so many
parodies on these trick shot videos
I don't know which one
our introduction to YouTube I feel like
when we met
um sniper
sniper yeah God I'm kind of tricked hey
man whatever yeah whenever it's too old
too but anyway okay
and I know that that's kind of what
you're known for but I know you reign as
the person who almost overdosed on a
live stream oh no
you didn't have to do that can you can
she hit the button
was she kind of she I did this and
uploaded it right this wasn't on a live
yeah so well she keeps talking she
relates it to her life okay let me
listen okay how come did he oh is that
true yeah yeah he's in a wheelchair
because of his yeah
I don't know about the live stream thing
but I do know he did have a problem he's
talked about it what drug was it
I watched a clip of him talking about
he like named all of the it was a whole
multitude it was a it was a it was a
cocktail I think you know a lot of npos
and uh a lot of what love a lot of face
members have had their issues
big old doinks of an issue I mean
honestly I feel like all this kind of
like content houses or probably this
type of houses though we were talking
about what his face because it's like
all these young kids I was doing drugs
at the same time the only difference was
I didn't have any money they have a ton
of money they're kids they are all in
the house I feel like it's such a recipe
for disaster apparently he was doing
benzos and opioids which is like death
City
uh yeah that's I mean that's horrible
that's you know not something you joke
about but people are amazing that he's
clean
good for him huge dub that's a dub let's
continue
um w
and I know that you're better now and
I'm really proud of you for that okay
but like she's trying to recover but she
clearly said it as a dig and I felt that
was really [__] up
like you you just just erase it what
you're known for but Yeshua was like
Untouchable in this situation
this is yeah I am so on her side
except I'm confused I'm not just this
part I'm confused but they do they do
talk about it later she says that it was
not mean spirit and he says that he
believes her so uh okay yeah
that
yeah for sure right exactly I personally
don't know how that's not mean-spirited
well I think so when you relates it to
her life more experienced at how things
might come off maybe or like maybe she I
don't know is she new to like this
online
stuff she's been streaming for a while
but she's not like
like them in terms of Competitive Gaming
no pizza experience yeah she's on it
so she's definitely doing a little bit
of a dig on them right but there's no
way yes 100 yes let's not make excuses
for her yeah it was 100 a dig at him it
rains kind of Defense of him like saying
all this stuff by about her has been
like always trolling this is like how we
did how we do it in the game that's yeah
that's also [__]
because in the game world it is like
everyone is super toxic at each other
and
sorry that's [__] I don't buy it I
mean if it is toxic that's like it's
just not good that it's toxic I'm saying
it as a defense to her actually oh it's
like he says he's down to scrap and like
all this and when she he when and I feel
like when he says that it kind of opens
yeah I mean he's like coming at her hard
and so yeah I feel like that was mild
compared to what he said well okay if
you well no I'm defending her there's
got it
I'm confused about everyone's point I'm
just going to read this please quit the
benzos and opioids he said I'm posting
this because I have severe nerve damage
all I know now is pain I can't walk
anymore and I get 30 seizures a day if I
knew this was possible I'd never have
been a [__] boy with drugs learn from me
yeah that's horrible definitely don't
combine those drugs
that's yeah not good yeah
yeah well that's good for watching I
know that that's kind of what you're
known for but I know you reign as the
person who almost overdosed on a live
stream
it's the way she laughs
she gives a smile and I know that you're
better now and
I'm really proud of you for that I am
because I grew up with a mom heavily
into drugs and
um you know those things when you're
little the things that you would make
wishes on like when you're driving under
a tunnel and you make a wish or you make
a wish on a dandelion or you make a wish
on a shooting star or anything like that
I made all of my wishes growing up that
my mom would get better and stop doing
drugs but she didn't
so I am proud of you for getting better
but
don't come after me for not knowing what
a trick shot is man
so my problem I like the anecdote she
didn't really tie it together in a way I
think that the smile was a nervous smile
because being seeing more of it she's on
the verge of crying so like it's a
nervous smile it's not like she was
laughing she didn't
tie it together where I was like okay I
understand why she brought that up yeah
she's like and don't ever cut and don't
ever talk do trick shots [__] on me
again
also just some I understand what she was
trying to say
like she's like I've been interested I
think so yeah
just some more context as well like she
stepped away from the movie industry
because there were some sexual advances
by undisclosed partner or not partner um
someone else involved oh I heard that
yeah she said she started streaming
because it's good for her mental health
and she switched to this world and now
this shit's happening so I'm sure it's
like it's a lot if this was her yeah she
thought gaming would be more welcoming
to girls
oh
yeah I think that
um
if she showed this to me I would have
said reshoot this and it didn't come off
right but I can see that maybe the
intention wasn't what it what it looks
like I think so too yeah and like as far
as things there's certain things that
you just don't make fun of people for
and obviously oh dang is one of them
yeah but is she okay let's keep watching
I mean he's
he said a lot of [__] about her but
she's like her point is I think oh I
don't know what trick shotting is but at
least I didn't OD
I don't think so it is look I don't
think that's the point okay well let's
see I we didn't finish it watch how she
ends it
don't come after me for not knowing what
a trick shot is man
like
we're not on the same plane
I don't know it's nice what she's saying
is don't come at me for such a stupid
thing I've been through enough [__]
that's how I understand it it's a
generous interpretation of it
uh
so
these are Discord messages in between
the time that they met up and the time
that they were doing those videos back
and forth he messaged her hey Grace I'm
sure Vera has told you or I hope so that
I really didn't mean those things and I
was just trolling I don't know you like
that or have anything against you and
I'm sure you're an amazing person
actually feels so bad that you felt and
I actually feel so bad that you felt
hurt I'm an idiot I should have known
people were gonna spam post that clip
genuinely sorry your feelings are hurt
I'm not sorry for the whole corporate
stuff though LMFAO but dude you just got
caught up in some unnecessary [__]
and it's not fair to you I want to clear
that out and only send Love Your Way for
real not on no lame ass PR [__] but I
genuinely felt bad and was putting
myself in your shoes and you just don't
deserve it but I hope you can understand
I really have nothing against you and I
was only trolling because you said you
wanted the barbecue a fairly good um
apology yeah
thoughtful
I thought it was funny how he's like
in the middle he goes
uh I'm not apologing for the corporate
stuff though LMAFO
I don't know
gamer moment
also uh just maybe you all knew this but
uh her dad is [__] Johnny Rico
Starship Troopers that's [__] awesome
what yeah that's the main character
right yeah that's another factor in this
is people are calling her like a nepo
baby and you know saying that's one of
the reasons that she got this besides
stranger things and yeah her her
grandfather is Robert Mitchum too who's
like an old-timey actor huh that is
interesting
I'm not gonna listen
I can't dislike someone just because of
the conditions they were born in no
definitely not yeah whatever yeah
okay well he made a fairly good uh
apology it would be nice to say
something similar in public yes so Grace
responds happy birthday rain I'm so
sorry for my out of line comment I
appreciate you for reaching out to me
outside of Twitter hell let me know when
and where tomorrow I can come to you so
they're gonna meet up seems good seems
like good it seems like uh the path to
peace agreed okay no it is World War II
really yes no she um
that he swears up and down no shot I'll
give you 10 million bucks if you can
find it
and then she comes with this weird
gotcha moment
oh man about a tweet oh that seems very
unnecessary yeah it was because she
messaged him being misogynistic and he
um denied it and then she was like well
I saw some of your old tweets about and
he was like I did not say that and then
it's this clip was that Rico guy and
other stuff I thought he was so good in
that movie not really anything else uh I
don't think he had that illustrious of a
career shame
which is also why it's kind of like
yeah she's a nepo baby but it's not like
not that big of an apple yeah I mean he
was he starred in one movie that I
believe was a flop at the time so it's
become beloved over time that movie was
a blockbuster now
um I was all about I could be wrong
about that but I don't think it did that
well God yeah a 110 million dollar
budget 121 million box office in the
green that's a no it's not in the green
you basically have to double the budget
to be like crazy I thought that movie
that movie blew my mind oh I love
Starship Troopers it's awesome I'm Paul
verhoven is the man that like one of my
favorite directors that movie is so
[__] good yeah okay so let's let's
get a load of this I did tweet some
crazy [__] I will give you 10 million
dollars if you can give me that tweet
seriously I want to see what I mean
where this starts with some crazy so he
put it out with his editorial commentary
yes so that's a little [__] up too
yeah so he gets to cut it and decide how
it comes off and put commentary I mean
that's not a lot of cuts to be fair to
him but yes he did he did but I did they
had talked about the publishing of the
video lots and like that he must have
like loved Emma Watts and I just
responded with some crazy troll [__] so
I'm just saying I'm being honest about
what I tweeted because I don't want him
to try to use it against me make it seem
like I'm something I'm not I don't even
know why I'm like over defending a 2013
tweet but it's just I know how these
[__] twist [__] bro you're
afraid to have any opinion you want over
my 16 year old tweet but I do apologize
I mean to be fair what he said was
horrible but it was nine ten years ago
yeah it was a long time
16. when do you when do you really get
so mad at something a 16 year old does I
mean they're all idiots six times that
Asian consent yeah exactly
some crazy [__] I mean I can leave I
will give you 10 million dollars if you
can give me that tweet seriously I owe
you 10 million I think he owes her 10
million got a tweet of me talking about
doing that I would give you 10 million
dollars 10 million I don't have 10
million I owe you for the rest of my
life from 2013. I don't he said he's
gonna have 10 million hell
uh care if it's from 2003 find it okay I
will I was so confident I was so
confident because I've never seen that
tweet resurface or anything posted a
2013 and never saw it again I put a link
and it's not my team I've never had a
crush on him a lot and that's so Random
I barely even know who she is no you
said I'm all that's an um I'll see if I
can find it right now someone responds
so wait why did it get brought up so she
didn't do like a gotcha but no she was
mentioning his misogyny and he denied
his misogyny and said that that's not
why he's angry and that wasn't a part of
his argument and she said no you you're
pretty misogynistic I mean I saw some of
your old tweets and then he was like
what tweet and then she brought it so
this whole this is all a very
unfortunate aside it seems like it is an
unfortunate aside yeah
and things got even worse he does owe
her 10 million dollars too
um he does say like oh [__] do I have I
have to like figure out how to get and
she's like no don't worry about it she
let him off the hook she did I would
have brought him I would have brought a
mediator I would have wired up there are
moments in this video like little
pockets of moments where they're both
being funny and nice to each other and
it's like oh so sad but two seconds
later they're so so close so close so
she didn't film her own version I'm
assuming no that was a mistake yeah
I feel like a lot of what she's doing
seems like rookie mistakes definitely
yeah I mean she's new to the game yeah
she's not a seasoned old uh War Horse
like us yeah she's longing the tooth
we've been through our [__] we've been
through it all girl
um he is misogynistic though oh yeah
it's hard to accept that though you know
what I mean it's it's it's a bitter pill
to swallow yeah one of my tweets with it
that's [__] insane there's no way I
would ever shoot them up
it's crazy
wait I saw a Clipper he was like that's
fake or is that coming no he says before
when she's pulling it up she's she's
like well it could be a fake he it could
be a fake screenshot like people make
fake
and so she pulled it up like through a
link oh we're very sexist things what
the [__] no absolutely I think because I
think no actually that's so crazy bro
what the [__] are we 10 million dollars
now
but yeah that there it was really scary
I'm really thinking like all right how
am I gonna pay her back now that's space
yeah you know um
the pillow my pillow guy yeah he put out
a bounty five million dollars to anyone
that can prove the election wasn't
stolen so a guy did do it and he said
I'm not paying you he sued him went to
court and the judge ordered Mike pillow
to pay him five million I love that
really yeah for real he won five million
the judge ordered him to pay WOW yes I
feel like I said five million doll hairs
or something how do you even argue that
look it up I'm dead serious so I'm
saying sheesh you know what I mean get a
lawyer
you're rich
look I'm really thinking that I'm like
wow I just lost 10 million dollars that
I have to pay I don't have to remember I
came in plan some I gotta figure it out
because that's like I was like [__] if I
figure out some sort of payment plan
let's do it you sure you don't want it
no I'm
on the right thing that I've never said
anything like that
he did yeah dude even here after that
kind of interaction it seems like yo
they're they're still making yeah they
get better they make progress so quickly
I can't wait to see what happens so this
is the the article by the guy who did it
actually the guy who did it interesting
is a republican I saw him interviewed on
remember where but
he's he's like a hardcore conservative
Mike Lindell dared anyone
yeah that's what he says he goes Mike
Lindell there to anyone to disprove his
claim that the 2020 election was stolen
from this software forensic expert it
was almost too easy
[Music]
um
I'm looking more for a headline than an
op-ed
but uh
but yeah yeah in January 2023 the
hearings were finally held we presented
our case Lindell presented his case
though he was only there for about an
hour to testify out of the four-day
hearing April 2023 decision was hand
down awarded me five million dollars wow
how [__] cool is that no that's a
[__] trick shot right there yeah
so are we done with this clip
um we saw the the stuff we needed to see
okay
so where does it go off the rail so we
are so not BFFs this is this is the
moment
all right I'm [__] hurt I almost died
and I called you mid and you let me go
back I'm super victimize yourself for
that okay then I guess I'm her he's
addressing her comment about his drug
use how dare you bring up the worst time
of my life was getting indignant leave
that one out I want me to do join us to
be demonized horrible humor for calling
you admit that I would love to touch on
my drugs I'm going to find the the
beginning of this it was that apology
yeah this needs more context yeah go
back home I just wish he wouldn't
[__] comment over it
I'm checking all this stuff I only saw
my interactions I don't really see
backlash to be honest I mean
sexism had no intention to hurt your
feelings and that's why I felt really
bad people think it's because of
backlash I don't give a [__] I don't
even see any to be honest because oh oh
it's out there okay well that's not my
homies weren't even mad about it come on
we all know how the internet works
bro you can't call her mid and then say
I'm not misogynistic it's just agree
it's just they're not compatible or say
that you didn't want to hurt her
feelings that's just like so malicious I
feel like these boys don't understand
that like they don't need to have the
like conscious dis they don't they don't
make the conscious decision to be sexist
in a moment like he's not it's not that
you chose to hurt her in that moment and
you were like I'm gonna be sexist right
now no the way that you think is that
she is already minimized compared to you
and that is showing and it's bleeding in
the way that you're speaking about her
and to her and that is the topic that
needs to be addressed and unfortunately
women are judged so much by how they
look that if you want to hurt her or not
a comment like that will hurt her right
you know
I mean there was indention to hurt my
feelings another one there was you asked
for a barbecue and I delivered
oh he's justifying it
he says you asked for reasons and I gave
you one your mid
what a George Foreman
and that's still hurting my feelings now
he's laughing at her now I know and I
understand and that's why I apologize
I'd like to note that the camera is
being handheld I'd like to know who's
filming that room right now y'all never
heard of a tripod damn
I don't know what else you would please
somebody do like a apology account of
how many times I've apologized to her
already for the same thing I think the
problem is it's the way you're speaking
in the moment yeah you're showing that
you're not apologizing this dude needs
to grow we're doing a lot of back
pedaling
over and over and over and over and over
again please including the one on
Twitter too don't don't leave that one
out want me to do join us to be
demonizing horrible humor for calling
you man that I want those on my drug
it's not like what do you want you want
me yeah now you're getting defensive and
the apology doesn't seem genuine does it
yeah forever just like who gives a [__]
yeah because it's like you want a super
victim now we hit her with who gives a
[__] and you're playing victim he's over
that okay then I guess it makes me
wonder if he even wrote that tweet
apology was that we saw
I think he did he has like certain
phases it's confusing like I've never
watched his content before but it's like
a lot of it is
coherent and it makes sense to me and I
understand where it lies and then he'll
make choices in the way that he speaks
to her like how he tries to prove his
argument and it's like oh my God you're
not doing this the way that you should
be if you're really trying to do
anything clearly he doesn't understand
how bad he's coming off right now yeah
how dare you bring up the worst comments
what's happening I'm [__] hurt how
dare you he's making fun of her saying
she was hurt
he's acting yeah well he's being super
super super uh dismissed he on one hand
wants to apologize and then on the other
hand he wants to be like stop being a
baby about it yeah you know
it's not how it works dude
it's like what are we talking about
I'm [__] hurt I almost died and I
called you man and your responses always
took my life that almost left my mom
without a son in support but bro bro
you want her to chill but then now look
how you're getting all of work though so
I could play that [__] game all day
I'm an actor too [__] [__] that game
come on yeah mean for what that's why
I'm thinking like was he just typing
like and laughing kind of like I'm gonna
I'm gonna type what they all wanna hear
you know yeah I mean baby
I mean this right now and then the the
commentary of him calling our [__] on
top is really sour babe I don't give a
[__] and it's like how could you let
other people hurt your feelings do you
not believe in yourself okay now we're
gonna lecture her for letting people
affect her feelings oh my God bro this
is not the time yeah no this part is so
[__] it's what I would have also
gotten up I apologize but don't you feel
a little stupid that you let anybody
affect your feelings oh my God
he's getting into some like pseudo like
brazzo [__]
are you not confident woman you should
be you should be you've accomplished
great things you should feel confident
Bro you've oh really you spent the whole
time belittling her accomplishments so
obviously that quote unquote compliment
is meant to uh
to be a jab
Ong how's this how's it turning your
feelings if I called you mid you should
be like [__] him who cares what I say
and if you bring up my drunk pass are
you getting emotional yeah well I I 100
understand why yeah she's getting sad
and he's being super aggressive he's
being super mean and his tone flipped
like a total 180 all of a sudden out of
nowhere totally actually I'm feeling
really I would feel played because it's
like all the him being a nice guy was
like a joke to him yeah and then all of
a sudden he gets so patronizing and so
personal can I ask the question how come
it looks like Zach is behind that couch
in the background
thank you
I mean he's like what are you getting
sad now [__] what are you getting sad
oh you let people hurt your feelings
dummy it's like dude oh why you thought
I apologized to you yeah [__] you I
apologize 20 times
I'm just speaking of truth I don't like
you
okay that's fine
I'm just being very logical I understand
how you feel but you brought things
you're not being logical you're being
stupid you don't understand how you feel
because you've spent the last 10 minutes
telling her that she shouldn't feel the
way she feels you're being so emotional
right now oh my God I forgot that he's
sitting there watching this all proud
told her a [__] she said I can act too
[__] yeah
I just saw him in their corner and I was
like oh my God he's also really proud of
this moment too very proud of it yeah
he's up against me terrible person
really yeah oh she's pulling that [__]
up now because I said that I'm pulling
the acting [__] out now how am I
terrible person
uh yeah she's just saying you're
horrible and at this moment I totally
understand her her hurt at this moment
for what pulling the acting
explain girl you don't have to do you
know what he's not your boyfriend he's
not your brother just leave you don't
have to be laughing girl he's watching
this and laughing girl you do not have
to deal with this man I don't think it's
wrong yeah
like he's not don't even sit there with
him anymore
he's right
100 did the right thing I would have
done exactly the same thing I would be
like why the F am I even sitting here
with you 100 yeah
I'm riding with her
um Macho tell Vera that I'm not doing
this video and if they release anything
then I'm leaving please
she's emotional I get it yeah
but again you should have said no joke I
do want the 10 million now
lawyering up you owe me ten she's yeah
she's
I don't think this video makes her look
in at that point he's just hiding there
behind the couch right kind of
disappointing you and Zach yeah I
thought you're there to protector yeah
I um
interestingly she said don't post this
video but I think it exonerates her and
makes him look like yeah oh yeah yeah
because until this I was kind of
thinking like that apology that he
really meant it but this clearly shows
it didn't mean anything yeah in that
apology we read this is even worse than
what he said the way he was aggressive
towards her like when she was being
vulnerable was just
Rock Bottom yeah
get [__] wrecked still holding on to
that huh while telling her not to be
emotional
listen she hit him with the hard R yeah
okay after that I'm heavily riding for
her yeah
okay the ultimatum the if you post this
I leave
um face posts a tweet in support of
Grace that says FaZe is no stranger to
contrasting viewpoints and passionate
opinions on the future of the brand
recruitment is always uh drawn that out
but make no mistake the mistreatment of
our newest member is in no way okay
grace joined in hopes to bring her voice
to phase and we stand by her
the [__] up
and then rain ratioed that the original
tweet had 12K his response has almost
60k and it says ratio show up your
dumbass bro this is your org you just
you're ratio and yourself [__] and a
little bit of okay check your stock
price
I mean what is who are just 50 000
people are they like 12 because he's
like a man child this is the this is
that was what I was trying to say before
it's the gamers did they're completely
done with this this is AB and preach
people they're like 28 years old
that's crazy
this is these people all know what trick
shots is I'll tell you that for sure
they all do that little dance and then
throw that little ball yeah or shoot
that little bullet what is sea bass yeah
so on the next slide there's a little
context sea bass is another guy in the
org and he very recently at the
beginning of May phase Reign threatened
to leave unless sea bass was fired from
the org
and he still works for the orc
so I'm I'm failing to understand his
point this is just I was telling you who
sea bass was when he responded shut up
sea bass the guy that he wants to be
fired who is a part of running
Seabass must have been behind that yeah
getting Grace
ah
you know what I mean he said he's
leaving did sea bass get kicked no no
and he's still there sea bass had a big
part in he was great he was a part of
Grace coming into phase I don't I just I
don't understand his point sea bass is
the dude he said needs to leave yeah or
he's gonna leave right he did not leave
and FaZe Rain also didn't leave it
didn't leave and he doesn't have 10
million so like he's a loser
that's a dig at himself yeah
because he's like
yeah remember that time I said I would
do this thing and I didn't and I didn't
okay he's up
I guess well he said he trick shots he
never claimed to be smart
he just has good reflexes yeah yeah yeah
Mr Banks had something to say he
responded you guys have lost it hold on
oh he's coming out he commented on the
phase thing too so he also ratioed them
uh blanks he couldn't even take the
enlightened Centrist oh wow he's just
straight up [__] girls are lame girls be
lying let's hear him out
let's hear him out
fair enough so Banks said you guys have
lost the plot to faze blanks
uh this comment says this situation is
about in such a bizarre way and now it
just feels like they're pushing this
narrative to distract from the original
problem
okay
first of all right you made it about her
if you wanted it to be about the issue
yeah then why the [__] did he make three
videos talking [__] on her dumbass
blanks how about you blame your [__]
friend instead dog piling this girl who
didn't do [__] you [__] FaZe blanks
what the [__] are you saying I'm saying
is empty bro all these guys who thinks
they're they're such badasses
entrepreneur right face and Banks why
don't you live the this company if they
lost the plot right I mean what they
apparently don't listen to you
so what do you do there is entrepreneurs
check out that stock bro
it's awesome
look at that not pretty that's
entrepreneurship right there brother
love hasn't FaZe Banks talked about
phase as well like calling them out
pretty much none of the original
Founders likes of his being handled
right now
um it's actually they do
I'll tell you these guys are good they
trick shot their own stock in the sense
that
in the course of [__]
in the course of just a few months
they went to almost zero and in the
course of a year they're going to be
delisted from their IPO that's
impressive that's the equivalent of a
Wall Street trick shot right
the Legacy continues
they're pro pro Gamers absolutely
exactly
yeah exactly I was just gonna say when
all these guys comment this kind of
stuff you know there are millions of
followers are gonna go [__] on her 100
and then they're gonna say oh I didn't
mean to hurt you yeah
they know the little baby you got hurt
yeah all their followers are a million
times meaner and oh yeah one million
percent know it yeah I mean you look at
the amount of likes his ratio got sixty
thousand so you can imagine the amount
of people who are just flooding her yeah
she was docs she was people yeah she was
getting harassed I mean just just look
at this from the beginning she joined
this org she was invited to join the org
she did nothing wrong and then he
basically now is trying to ruin her life
yeah I mean that's that that's the
outcome he's just pulling her down with
this greater thing and then ironically
he's blaming her as being a distraction
which he created from the real point
wow what a [__] uh tangle of idiocy
it's so dumb I really think the the
moral is that the phase org people is
they don't want women in there no they
don't I think it's gonna wrap it up I
think it's time to wrap it up yeah yeah
we should face down let's wrap let's
just let's wrap it up take it easy guys
so here this is fun how have our faves
responded Aiden Ross I'm pretty sure I
know how he's gonna respond okay okay
but after seeing all this I'll I'll say
this
W she what she said which she said in
that moment
she shouldn't have done but on the whole
I'm 100 writing for her and faze rain
is frankly a monster
peace out that's my take all right Aiden
let's see what you got she's a [__]
monster get her out he's a corporate
demon she's a [__] succubus is he
defending her is he being ironic he's
being ironic get her out I never got
them she's she's a [__] monster wait
that's it did he not expand on that
he goes just kidding and then he keeps
he keeps streaming so in a sense I would
say I think Aiden is perhaps defending
her perhaps but I need more context
conclusion I think Aiden just defended
he was parodying and we are talking
about Aiden Ross so I'm not gonna assume
that he has again he's probably a bad
intentions I think he's just thinking
about what the couch smells like under
FaZe Rain
okay interesting well thought out uh and
a fantastic take by Aidan Ross
Hassan
all right Hassan
don't [__] this up
how can Hassan [__] this up the last
part about this is a huge phase Banks
fan no right he keeps saying that bass
is always the sun is that you're ugly
like I wouldn't even hit on you if I was
drunk like brother that's probably a
good thing okay
yeah because at that point I think we're
talking and you know what I'm not even
gonna make the joke yeah no I think you
know
I think you should you should stay away
until you re-evaluate your [__]
values okay never let touch me on my
drunkest night I would never let you
touch me sounds like he's
he's right on the money as usual thank
you aligned not my drunkest night like
anyone that [__] goes off and says oh
man you [__] went off King you went
off on this [__] oh [__] like
you [__] popped off brother you
killed it like
anyone that thinks that is is a [__]
12 year old goober okay well and what's
interesting is he's not even responding
to yeah the worst part which is the
video rain put out
so okay thank you Hassan always can
count on you for the good takes
as men gold okay this is a wild card
yeah he's been coming out with some
weird takes
so hmm I don't even know where this is
gonna go they hired her and gave her a
bunch of [__] money to act like a
broom to clean up all these crackheads
and they're [__] up their [__] ups
this The Phase Clan has had fuck-ups for
10 years and they hire her to play
damage control for a bunch of [__]
crackheads I like he's calling them
crackheads but I don't know why he's
putting too much on her she's not a
broom she's not a cleaning house she's
just a girl so he's just saying that
they hired her to try and turn around
the image of things which I think is
that I think that's a parasite okay fair
she says
um when they meet that like she just
wasn't anticipating hate from inside the
house she was anticipating it from the
outside like the people from the org
like warned her about it but she was
saying if you guys had this much of a
problem with me before they announced it
why didn't you talk to me so that I
wouldn't be so like then she wouldn't
have been so embarrassed and like posted
about everywhere like human like if she
could have been prepared for it it would
have been a lot different I think if she
knew that these people how do you prefer
her listen we don't like girls here I
don't know
they should have strapped her to a chair
propped open her eyes Clockwork Orange
style and watched [__] 24 hours
straight of trick shot montage
assimilation yeah
okay let's let's watch this a bunch of
[__] crackheads
she made a mistake she should have never
[__] been
out and the [__] out that's kind of why
I was asking and that's why I even want
a giant face I think at that point it's
almost on principle like if she leaves
then they're gonna feel like they won
right she took phase out of her bio oh
she said she's yeah I don't blame her
either no I don't blame her either she
went private took it out of her bio
she's probably getting so much hate yeah
crying about how oh it hurt my feelings
oh it it like it almost took it away
from me almost took my son away from me
[__] you took your you almost took your
mom's son away from yourself
rain rain
you want to talk about being logical who
put the pill in your
in your [__] okay
very good it's a good little phase Reign
and be able to last five minutes in a
Modern Warfare 2 lobby after this
you were you were pushing back against
me but that's why I was saying it wasn't
really that bad what she said it's like
in the grand scheme of like how these
guys always [__] talk it's like no no no
you can't apply it to everybody I'm
sorry they know he's 27. he knows that
some I'm sorry
sorry I don't buy it that all being said
asman popped the [__] off
yo why does he sound a little bit like a
Bill Burr here
did you see that yeah yeah okay a bunch
of grandkids
I don't know who put the bill in his
mouth yeah
I'll tell you one thing I don't know a
phase Reign would be able to last five
minutes in a Modern Warfare 2 lobby
after this what a [__] ass [__] okay
wow I was wrong
was a [__] great thing
that's a bad one I was used to good ones
but then there was a few weird ones but
he's back he's back back we're so bad
there's been a couple there's a little
bit of Shaky Ground in the past couple
months but he's back he's back that was
that was actually and I love the way he
delivered it too yeah that was good
very good
I want to watch it again a bunch of
[__] money to act like a broom to
clean up all these crackheads and
they're [__] their [__] ups
this The Phase Clan has had [__] ups for
10 years and they hire her to play
damage control for a bunch of [__]
crackheads
she made a mistake she should have never
[__] been in there
she should have seen that she should
have gotten the [__] out
and that's a fact
crying about how oh it hurt my feelings
oh it it like it almost took it away
from me almost took my son away from me
[__] you took your you almost took your
mom's son away from yourself
you want to talk about being logical who
put the pill in your [__] mouth
what a [__] [__] I'll tell you one
thing I don't know a phase Reign would
be able to last five minutes in a Modern
Warfare 2 lobby after this whatever
[__] ass [__]
I gotta say that's one of the best
roasts I've seen that was so good he
popped off like a masterpiece you know
as Ben I hope you see this you pop that
was beautiful I had to watch it twice
yeah that was that was really good
[Music]
oh
I can't imagine Ms Kiff taking taking
his side well that'd be shocking to me
please don't miss
don't do it
this is my thing they already knew what
my position of faces I was exposing
everything from numbers you didn't have
a face to hate for sure but like why
would they even put you in that position
why would they put you in a position
knowing what would happen you think
there's not one percent chance that they
thought it was going to go well but they
didn't deserved of me for sure but
that's why I said it's never a page
and people have found my number yeah I
mean I don't know they so they yeah they
knew FaZe Rain was going to be a
complete prick that they knew that thank
you everybody sees this yeah even Aiden
Ross right couldn't even really defend
phase right maybe we were a little we're
all clear on that it's too unclear I'm
not gonna give him the benefits
so but now who's liking his tweets
because everybody
with a voice that's a good question is
like this guy is a [__] idiot people
rated bro it's the MMORPGs versus the
first person shooter stood oh yeah
it's like what the [__] did you just say
the what uh okay
let me um let me continue yeah I mean I
don't know they so that yeah they knew
face Reign was going to be a complete
prick that's exactly such a good point
they knew that
yeah he's like yeah they know me I'm I
hate women they should have known better
than to mix us
what the hell why is he not just say
always to say is I'm sorry I went way
too far I was trolling if he wants to go
that route I didn't mean it I hope we
could be okay if not I understand that's
all I used to say what is he doing I'm
so confused
or how they found my number that's
something obviously I don't want and I
never directed hate towards you towards
you the reason I said what I said was
because like why does she even do that
phase bro if you watch my original I
can't win him in the corner watching
himself so happily he's the voice of God
throughout this year
it's like I'm okay with one of you I
don't need two of you
that's what Fizz had to say about that
yeah and um
uh rain had something mean to say about
Miz and then ER yeah yeah and then
wait hold on someone they made up on
Twitter
let me pull it up are they friends yeah
they like they made up on Twitter I mean
it wasn't that bad what he said no I
know it was something to me like FaZe
rains an emotional little baby I sent
you something
okay
oh Aiden Ross we got more details he's
not a terrible person back him up it's
my brother right here maybe let me go
back
uh
this is a script I'm just being honest
listen bro
he's not a terrible person back him up
it's my brother right here my older
brother literally rain's a good ass
person bro great dude Aiden's families
Andrew Tates his daddy FaZe rains his
brother dude y'all know I have no doubt
there was gonna be something like that
in there when I opened up on my lead
addiction the first thing he did was
call me bro talk to me for 30 minutes
bro I love this [__]
Well yeah if he can defend Andrew Tate
he couldn't defend anyone yeah yeah I
mean his stance is basically I don't
care what's in the video I don't care
what I see or what happened this guy was
nice to me yeah
the good guy that's a loyalty yeah don't
you know what loyalty is anymore
I called you that one time
yes I was extremely nice to hear that
one time
and now you come to me with this
disrespect
there's no loyalty left in this world
you remember that time I brought you a
donut it was 3am
we had gone out drinking and
I reached for my credit card before you
could and I bought you that donut
and now you go against the family
loyalty 10.
remember that time I bought you a
Jiffy peanut butter flashlight
yes
how am I terrible person for what
pulling the acting how was my favorite
person explain
okay she doesn't need to explain you are
um or at least you're you are being in
that moment I mean so that's it yeah
there it is well well so it was Olivia
oh my God thank you
I'm glad I finally got up to date on
this and yeah it really is not that con
I don't think there's really even two
sides to this conversation I mean no if
you have a brain he took it so far and
he was so mean and rude to her for no
reason Miss Kiff and Rain squashed the
beef thank God
here they are my
Smiley could you put the Tweet over
their picture why do I gotta do like
this
all right so uh phase yeah he takes back
what he said I don't know if it actually
happened he's talking about the
situation with Miska from last year he's
like I guess I I hear that you cleared
up whatever happened there my fault and
then he says the gray stuff
Ms gift please look into that and
realize what I meant I've been trying to
resolve all of this the whole time and
then he says this made me tear up
someone taking back what they said I
appreciate you not blindly attacking me
and apologizing I followed you back and
we can talk if you want so they had that
moment
after the thing we watched
lovely lovely that was a beautiful cap
on it letting you know it seems to be
about them and not anything to do with
her y'all just yeah keeping you in the
loop you know what I mean thank you well
it's almost like therefore Miz almost
pulled a you were nice to me homie too
because he's like because Fizz was in
that big old controversy yeah and he's
like yo bro I take back what I said and
he's like okay then I take back what I
see I'm literally sobbing right now I'm
literally right now
although to be fair to Ms he didn't
really even say anything that bad so
I think rain's being a baby
uh there it is FaZe Rain Chrissy phase
up
Year Mom and FaZe blanks coming in
running deep for his boy
[__] love it oh miss Kiff has a
rumble show which is like wow
blanks that to me is pretty rock bottom
get in that bag
he was working for Nazis basically right
well maybe that's a little harsh
Peter Thiel so yeah white supremacist so
uh yeah
I want to see his show actually
he's actually on the sidebar huh next to
Trump Dave Jimmy door
this whole website is literally just
endocrine indoctrination with ultra
conservative freak [__] anyone that goes
and takes a a deal with them your main
lining anyone that comes and watch it to
Jimmy Dore you guys
and then where's he on the side why do
all this Crowder why are all these
Brands okay with being here like Zelda
it's not that no they're not partnered
there's live streaming it's just they
just put the picture up okay yeah I
don't think they have any sponsors it's
just backed by Peter thale who's like a
mega mega billionaire I see and he's
like uh super politically active psycho
right-wing freak and um
this is what he does
this is why conservatives are so rich
and Libs like me
I'm so broke
at least I don't have a sugar daddy
I wonder how long I'll be able to
sustain this because there is no way
that this is not hemorrhaging money
like hardcore so I don't know we'll see
how long it lasts
um so wait where did you I want to see
mizkiff's show where is it
but here's a who who Who's Who of psycho
[__] her router Crowder Reuben yo Reuben
their top featured stream right now has
672 people watching yeah and then they
say that Crowder apparently gets like 2
million views per episode
that's what they say you believe that
because Steven did an exclusive deal
with them or I think it's with a v
and there I
they've got to be fudging the numbers
like crazy
um here it shows the views
he didn't even get this many views on
YouTube and they're trying to make me
believe that not only did every single
person come over to rumble to watch him
which
at best case you're gonna get like 30
all right that's like it's just
basically impossible it's impossible
yeah that these are getting a million
views it's impossible
they're probably getting like 50 000
I'll be straight up
maybe a hundred thousand
watch it
but where did you say is next to Trump I
didn't see what you're talking about
on the left side I think the bar my bar
is different than yours so um Ian may
have had something different when he
pulled it up yeah
just screams too it's just like a normal
stream
no I don't even think it's simulcasting
this one
bro he only has 10 000 followers like
this this website is pointless it's just
to get the message yeah it's just about
the money I think here's what it does
because Kai snack
and speed speed are also making a show
on this clearly they paid them a
shitload of money with the hopes of main
lining a bunch of young uh
yeah men
uh impressional men into hardcore
conservative values that's what it is
it's blood money man it's crazy yeah
should be live
just a thank you he puts no effort into
this I feel like he's playing wrong not
surprised
there it is
first stream on Rumble baby
I was gonna move to one of those
platforms
kick because if that goes south you can
pull the ninja move get the bag and then
go back to Twitch because he made like
what 30 mil or something off of uh mixer
and then they closed down shortly after
but it's not even exclusive yeah I don't
think Mischief would ever do an
exclusive with anyone it's just this is
literally just a bag and he can keep
streaming on Twitch
that's true I mean is it worse than uh
than gambling bag what's worse Rumble
bag or gambling
good question rumble's not a league I
mean
it's not even morally or it's not even
like gray area for legal so that's a
plus
uh
but yeah I mean they're both pretty
pretty big pretty shitty things w
if you're a lib like me anyway which I
think he probably is a lib he's a dirty
lib
yo let me watch Jimmy Dore man
oh it's private I have to sign up [__]
hold it
so there it is uh thank you Olivia yeah
thank you for your time
Chrissy FaZe up Chrissy
Chrissy face what's up I said face up no
get that hey don't combine how do you do
with this face
Grace up
we should do cheese
trick shot
that was dope
well uh let's see what else we can hit
on here real quick oh Tana I wanted to
watch Tana's response to the idubbb
apology there's a response yeah she did
a podcast oh I haven't seen so um
does that seem good seems good right
let's watch it yep
and my
um who's is this just her girly who's
this
yeah that's her best friend Brooke is
she an influencer or just a normie um
she co-hosts the podcast with her she uh
wasn't a content creator before Tana
okay
my Instagram
mentioning you in their story and it's
not like
random people it's like
news things and that's never usually a
good thing like if I wake up and my
Instagram DMS are like me being tagged
in a bunch of [__] news accounts and
like press things story like I usually
did something that I'm going to have to
then apologize for I click on one and it
says idubbbz has apologized to Tana Mojo
I'm like checking the date I'm like is
this April Fool's Day like what's what's
going on I just
I sooner thought I would die before I
would ever see anything like that and
it's funny because like two weeks ago
Oscar was like you would have the most
viral episode of canceled and like it
could be good for you to have idubbbz on
and like try to squash
and I think he is going on a show right
that's interesting he is good man I'm
sure I think that'll be really good for
them
if I don't even know if you can call
that beef or just talk about things like
you know what I mean blah blah and I was
like telling him like I would sooner
have on Joe Biden like and it would
never happen in the sense that like I
didn't ever think he would you know what
I mean I didn't want to like hey like
we've never talked one time like ever
ever we've never well you did talk that
one time foreign
well there was that one time
that one time yeah you know what I mean
the game earlier talk though did she
even say anything I can't remember no
she just got freaked out and then ran
off yeah yeah
and I guess he posted this apology video
apologizing for like a bunch of things
he did in the past one of them being the
video he made with me or like to me or
something and I was like damn
like
I just never expected that and I don't
know how I feel about it you know
because like
and I don't know how to say this I'm I'm
not talking about
anything in regards of the things he
said but I'm I'm more so just talking
about like his actions to me like you
know him showing up to my show him kind
of putting me on blast him inevitably
making me kind of canceled and lose
subscribers and have to apologize and
all that type of stuff I I kind of think
I like deserved that and maybe that's
like dark like to say but like I don't
feel like I'm owed an apology and maybe
that's because I've accepted it so much
that like people always ask me if you
could go back in time and like make that
never happen like would you and I always
say no because I feel like
at the time it was obviously
a very
what's happening over there
Oscar goes cry you heard him
like it was a very dark time period of
my life when it came to like
self-reflection and trying to figure
[__] out and like I think I would be a
completely different person if I didn't
have that I think it like I was on track
to just be so on my high horse and like
egotistical and like nothing could go
wrong that something going wrong gave me
such a dose of reality that like this
might not last forever like yeah you
need to be held accountable for actions
you I don't know like it like it made me
do so much necessary growth and I think
it also changed the entire trajectory of
my career in life like I don't even
think canceled would be here if like I
didn't
get canceled a bunch till and that was
kind of the start of that to like shape
that brand for me like it wasn't like I
went into this being like I'm canceled
like I'm scandalous like if anything I
wanted to be brand safe to an extent you
know what I mean and just like
everything I I feel like it really
shaped the course okay sounds like
everybody's very interesting yeah
everybody's growing and we we were
impressed with Tana she's mature he's
great she's cool I I thought she was
awesome yeah and um you know listen this
was all a long time ago I really like
who she's become today I love her yeah I
think she's really cool she's been
through a lot and and and Ian's been
through a lot of interesting stuff too
and
great I I think it'll be a nice podcast
the two of them
I mean there's other stuff she says here
she was provoking him and just looking
back as well I think even at the time I
was more like you know I can't believe
all of this is happening but like you
were poking the bear like I was the one
who mentioned him first and that's right
at the time I had this boyfriend who was
like so obsessed with him and I just
like although a Tweed is and well
whatever yeah you all will have a good
episode yeah good for you guys
you want to see the most unhinged Tick
Tock ever
this dude um he found God
and he wants everyone else to find God
too
but he's seniors he has a somewhat
interesting story
um
take a listen and tell me if you find
this inspiring
or weird
when I was 18 years old I had a Snapchat
that I snapchatted younger girls on
because I got off to flirting with
younger is this music gonna get us in
trouble I did not get claimed thank you
so much thank you the sexual way shortly
after that I began watching and going on
a grinder to hook up with transgenders
because I got off to these things I
hired prostitutes that were transgenders
no I had sex with many women I used to
watch murder porn and when I was having
okay back it up Jesus you you threw in
Murder porn
okay like it's on the same level as
seeing a prostitute we need to take a
few steps back here buddy you said what
now had sex with many women I used to
watch murder porn can we pull that
attack
I mean sure
that's very dark but he said you said
what yeah I gotta hear that exactly what
the [__] any women I used to watch
murder porn and when I was having sex
with my wife who I falsely married
ourselves to justify sex
falsely married what do you mean falsely
because he falsely married her God I got
it got it oh what does that mean because
he he doesn't actually like her falsely
marry each other watch pornography of
strangulation and murder dude stop what
the [__] are you saying
wait back up you said you had PR you had
slept with prostitutes you slept with
trans people you're trying to [__] dudes
let's back it up let's erase all that we
need to back it up okay let's talk about
you watching murder porn unless it's
only been 30 seconds you know said so
much
guy here to review this please
close my eyes and think about killing
her wait
stop dude you you you you ah you cannot
we're just scrolling thick dog here this
man's wanting you to find God I also
always have to remind myself he has his
hit he's like holding this he's like I
used to watch murder porn I used to
fantasize about killing my wife [__]
dude this man is legitimately I also
love the little title dark past yeah
putting it mildly dude you put a border
on it all nice yeah listen sleeping with
trans people and seeing prostitutes
you're good you know what I mean
uh murder porn
no is he talking about like real murder
porn like dark web [__] yeah like where
do you even find that
I don't know all I know I didn't even
think that's far you know and then we're
gonna go there in my head for sure I'm
pretty sure that's illegal to possess
dude this man needs to be in prison I
want him in prison
Jesus can't save you bro you know they
say like if there's any doubt like when
you're in a jury I kind of don't have
any doubt here that he did something
wrong in jail we don't know what he did
but he did something something wrong
happened well no he admit he admit to
watching murder porn that's not legal
well I don't know it could be like fake
like acting where do you find that I
don't know
maybe we can do it another tick tock
what is recommendations I was having sex
with her and get off to these things I
tell you dude let me back it up get off
of these things
hold on her while I was having sex with
the geography of strangulation and
murder I used to in my mind close my
eyes and think about killing her while I
was having sex with her and get off to
these things yeah he's being very
vulnerable whoa
you know his his I'll say this his
openness is refreshing yeah
true he's very candid I mean he's really
laying it all out there
so that's kind of a touching
men are men need to practice being more
open like true killing themselves
yeah he's somewhat inspiring yeah
I told you she's gone right you guys are
divorced
I'm hoping yeah so I hope she's not like
amazing or something yeah do we know
where she is is she good time is running
out and I don't care if I'm perceived as
a pedophile homosexual murder
next to murder also he said pedophile he
didn't say anything about kids right now
yeah he did in the beginning what do you
say about kids he started off by saying
he would talk to young girls oh right
but he was getting off of it Snapchat he
opened with it
those was an appetizer you know what's
[__] up because like this is so
shocking that if it came up on my feet I
probably would watch but then what what
is the algorithm going to show me next I
don't want to know that's part of the
problems I do want to know because I
like didn't know anything about makeup
so I was watching a lot of tutorials now
all of my fate is just makeup stuff and
I'm exhausted it is a pitfall of the
algo because something it's stupid you
get a morbid curiosity for stuff that
you hate excitement exactly if I'm
afraid of looking at things because I
don't want it to become myself and on
the other hand I'm looking for something
for educational thing but then when I
want to scroll recreationally I don't
want to watch education you end up on
murder talk one thing that I've started
snuff talk I started um
um consciously now when I there's
something up that I don't want to watch
that's like disturbing or whatever
I I scroll off yeah I don't watch it
because usually it puts me in a bad mood
too and I was like this Mother's this
mother strangled her five-year-old to
death I'm like yeah I don't need to
watch this time is running out and I
don't care if I'm perceived as a
pedophile homosexual murderer if it
helps you understand that anyone can
come to God and come home and be
forgiven and turn you're not forgiven I
don't buy it then come home and use me
as a foolish example to come back to
Christ okay oh my God you're telling
okay
you're telling me that just by finding
God you stop doing all those things I am
not buying it I'll tell you this try
again I don't want to be a member of any
[__] club that has him in it yeah
if Jesus Christ is down with this guy
then I don't wanna I don't want nothing
to do with that team
oh my God is he he said like uh if I'm
perceived as a p word or murder like a
murderer how did you perceived as a
murderer did you either you killed
someone or you don't
bro yeah very good point no did you
murder yourself
around that accusation yeah where's that
wife he was talking about right I
genuinely genuinely genuinely hope the
FBI is watching him oh well actually if
you go to 3B
as a matter of fact wait FBI uh
mentioned
let's see don't play with us you guys
he linked his cash app to detectors show
up at my house
he said um
he said he links his cash up his venmo
and his Paypal
it is Ministry his ministry
oh he's a cult leader then who
I think he's just doing a scheme so he
can
oh my God that follow-up
all right let me watch this today I had
two detectives show up at my house
church with the Catholics is who they're
working with I dare you to complain
about it how is the church
this guy goes he goes I don't care how
people perceive me and they even be like
the police showed up in my house because
they perceived me so let's see if let's
watch him complain about this maybe the
Catholics the overseers of Houston Texas
are trying to get in touch with the FBI
essentially not
not Church okay cool thank God so I'm
down with the Catholics except for
everything else at least they had enough
sense to be like no not you
not you this is so good Jesus accepts
everybody not you I love this dude this
Duo this Tick Tock Duo it's straight up
at the Pearly you know part one part two
it's amazing they say if you accept
Jesus
you go to heaven no matter what you did
right at the Pearly gate it's gonna be
like all right not healed but I did the
Jesus thing no yeah not you though
I suppose that's understandable when you
the devil's doctrines knowing that it
completely contradicts Jesus in Matthew
6 7 when it says not to pray in vain
repetitions don't bring up Matthew 67. I
don't need no Bible quote to contradict
what you said
I don't need a Bible quote to know that
watching murder porn ain't right
music is cracking me up and it's also so
much louder than his dialogue like
barely hear him there was another one of
his that did get claimed but in it he
essentially just says that Satan God and
Jesus are all watching you in a circle
while you masturbate so think about that
they're doing a circle joke he's like
you he's like no no they're all around
you that's why you shouldn't be doing it
sinful they're always watching it's like
the name of that girl on the couch yeah
[Laughter]
what are we doing when you pray the
rosary summoning evil spirits John this
man is in a gas station you are the evil
spirit if anybody is hold the phone this
man is in a gas station parking lot
this man is straight up at Chevron not
John 14 verse 6. does he have someone
filming him too yeah oh my God
14 or six it says there's no way to the
father in
no loitering please
can you guys shoot this somewhere else
we'd already got kicked out of
McDonald's parking lot
Catholics are angry because their false
religion is being exposed oh he's going
against all Catholics sick yeah we're
Team Catholics on this one
so here's the here's the problem this is
the only time I've been team Catholic
here's the problem
I don't like that this guy is like
taking the lead you if you should just
simmer down
you know put on a robe maybe castrate
yourself and just listen to what other
people tell you to do I don't like that
he's like no I'm cut bringing it to the
Catholics no they say murder prone is
wrong I say what's wrong
I mean he like what evidence do we have
that he's changed
why should anybody trust he said so
women are not here did you see the video
I'm very glad that the police are on to
him though
uh this one has 43 000 likes by the way
so wow let me read the comments out
insane take
uh oh why am I still single supposed to
be speaking in churches probably because
you kill all your significant others yes
that would make it hard to stay in a
relationship and you kill them
oh no Shredder what happened
Shredder puked oh
I puked him
in a while was it alfredo
Alfredo puked last night
could have been the Fredo
I can tell by smelling his birth
what are you doing
Ethan's digging through the puke right
now
he's going in raw he ate an onion which
is poisonous to dogs
how did you get an onion
[Music]
give it a taste look at it
that's really bad yeah it's really bad
I'm glad he puked it out was that you I
don't know if it's him though because he
doesn't smell people
not really
not really sure so if he was Alfredo
then I'm also concerned because that's
the third time Alfredo's puked I don't
was it you Freddie here let's see is
there puke on his lower jaw I know it
was you've riddle
yes please this is
oh his jaw is wet here
oh no alfredo actually I'm relieved it
wasn't Shredder because
Alfredo he'll be fine why are you
keeping you know well he he we did all
Labs he's totally healthy it's probably
good that he picked it out it's just
that small amount I would only be
worried if it was Shredder why are you
looking as puke Shredder
maybe he's telling us he's a dog he's
trying to tell you like look
I wish I knew who let me see your shirt
dry yeah I feel like I can immediately
tell if he was Trader
Fredo what happened to you
thank you Lena
what are you afraid of but Shredder's
licking his lips
yeah he's hungry
let me get some of that it smells good
yeah I don't know why he keeps puking
though I wonder if he needs to see the
vet
but we did a full LAB Works full
everything on him recently and he's like
totally healthy
look he's so cute
why are you so cute you little pukey
he seems fine otherwise
so wasn't you Shetty come here
is a little wet I'm worried
just get in there
smell here I did I don't smell puke
I don't smell puke Shredder wasn't you
you know Shredder hasn't puked in so
long it had me feeling we're so good
because it's a Sim it's one of the
symptoms of
the kidney failure but he's been in such
good health Shredder you just want some
of that puke huh Shredder don't stop
[Music]
there's dog food right there can you eat
that
I can have the vet come check out
Alfredo maybe we should because I think
we're going to be paranoid now all
weekend
well they're Nina they're coming to do a
blood test on Shredder soon right yeah
what date is that on uh let me double
check
we can if it's soon we could just have
him check on
um Tuesday actually Tuesday so can you
can you let her know that Alfredo's been
puking just to do a checkup on him okay
you want to schedule for him too yeah
yeah okay whatever she thinks
okay we need we should do it maybe
mentioned that we saw onion
yeah it was so small tiny but still he
was puking already okay yeah I'll
describe it
um
great
I can't get enough of this guy ah
man this is like True Detective [__]
this must be like my favorite Tick Tock
Saga I've ever witnessed
it's I have mixed feelings though at the
same time I know but that's why it's so
good women are not supposed to be
speaking in churches
speak and die
here at my Ministry women speak women
die find God men are not supposed to be
taking Authority roles where have the
men gone is there not a single dude
you're supposed to be fixing yourself
this is not fixing this is not good
where have the man gone oh man to preach
or lead now you walk into most
mainstream churches and there's a woman
leading the entire city
a Catholic Church
maybe really maybe yeah you know where
you want to see women
around him because he killed them all
just a little ironic that is
the gospel it says here in first Timothy
chapter 2 verse 11 let a woman learn in
Silence with all submission and I do not
permit a woman to teach this dude's
about to find out in the Bible that
killing a woman's okay he's so close
right he's so close to saying Jesus told
me to kill her yeah he's right there
a a Blade's Edge away you might say
or to have authority over a man but to
be silent listen to this part for Adam
yeah I bet you like that Bible don't you
freak was formed first then I wonder who
wrote that by the way
a man
uh-huh it's like yeah yeah so uh anyway
I wrote this really cool book it says
that women need to be subservient
yeah and they need to just be quiet
and uh
like I didn't say that the book said it
make dinner
[__]
it's in the book
Eve and Adam was not deceived but the
woman being deceived fell into
transgression meaning was it the man
that fell or was it the woman it was the
woman who fell and just like Kingston
just like when I stabbed them they fall
it's always the woman falling
um he said that he never met one
righteous woman women are to be quiet
bro he is so close to murdering Again
Church address
never taking a place of authority and
unfortunately the normality is women
leading church services I'm
unfortunately I'm genuinely curious what
he thinks a woman's role is because it
seems like he's saying they can't talk
they can't have an opinion
like genuinely what is a woman's role
which is so funny considering a doll
with actually no life because he likes
them then yeah just a doll Cannonball
it's like a [__] yeah
he's so dumb like you're gonna do it are
you sure maybe a girl should do it
yeah it's modestly and to be silent
never taking a place of authority and
unfortunately the normality is women
leading church services
basically that's why I kill them it's
kind of their fault
if they weren't trying to lead all these
Bible groups I wouldn't be having to be
killing women all the time it's because
I'm doing like a Karen where he's like
look here it says women should not be
allowed to speak
like who can I talk to the manager of
the church it says here and Jesus are
you gonna do something about this
biblically true or aloud let me talk to
your dad
[Music]
this guy's psycho apparently about 11 of
congregations
uh are led by women in the United States
we need that number higher
now he's saying lower he's saying that's
way too high he says it's everywhere
dude he looks so unhinged in these two
he's like I'll see what I cannot go back
his face is all [__] up his hair is
greasy he's in a parking lot somewhere
yeah I go back to pornography and just
because there's so many dude you kill
you literally
afraid of breathing huh okay
okay yes
people making it normalize that they're
falling back into it you cannot go back
it's against the word of God it's
against the Covenant in second
Corinthians chapter 5 verse 17 therefore
anyone in Christ is a new creation old
things have passed away oh is this
getting claimed because this wasn't once
I'm cleared yeah you better
[Music]
yeah dude let's not let's not tell
people what kind of porn they can watch
from you I mean
from the murder porn guy it's exploding
Milk porn don't judge my exploding Milk
porn please you know
well there you go that's pretty fun
um here's one more just since we're on
the topic of weirdo Alpha freaks okay
this clip is nuts you got to endure
people are too you want a second
are just why is it not removing the gray
one that might be in this
this guy who was the best and brightest
dollar store fresh and fair what would
you recommend okay
gray screen
Tick Tock [__] with me all the time
what grade is great you see how it's
like it won't it's staying grayed out
that's right extreme example it's Reddit
you said why is Tick Tock you're you're
on Reddit right now Reddit why are you
doing this I'm trying to do a podcast
here hello I mean you hear that Reddit
is killing this is totally [__] off
topic but I just found this out this
morning they're killing all third party
apps
like if you why because they're like
trying to try to solve it yeah they're
trying to charge like millions of
dollars to use their API to call stuff
so basically it's gonna kill every app
other than the official one
um which is awful what does that mean I
never really used the third party stuff
I know there's like the advanced suite
and all that [__] what do you use you
use Reddit on your phone yeah what app
do you use I do it in my browser I do
too oh you'll be okay I refuse to use
their [__] app yeah and I saw Ethan
refusing and so I refused to yeah their
app has [__] awful it's dog [__] but
there's a lot of third-party ones that
are actually really good but uh they for
some reason have decided to completely
kill that so uh rip rip to Reddit
so it might be like physically abusive
because you probably endure people
browsers
okay okay you got to watch this this is
for you
okay all right here we go one more time
here we go
physically abusive you got to endure
people are too you want to stick arches
are just situation that might be in that
situation what would you recommend okay
it is such an extreme example she's
talking a lot of [__] so I was getting
[__] angry because like
like
listen listen
and this is why this is why you live in
Japan man
and I don't I'm not trying to advocate
for you know wait this wait what hold on
what is this clip what the [__] this is
the dudes in the clip the commentating
on it later
I wanted to watch the original clip this
is almost even crazier holy [__] yeah no
this is crazy
oh yeah this is the second one it's just
a lot to follow here I don't know what
I'm watching yeah because this is the
second one this one's called the endure
man exposes himself as an abuser I need
the original clip okay you guys don't
have that one in here
see that let me find
let's find it because this is no
interesting uh uh Duracell if anybody
knows what I'm yeah yeah
no no no MLB is Shadow Boxing he has
Shadow Boxing right now that's what he
is doing we are not endorsing anything
like that but yeah it's it's modern
women can only speak to to men in this
way because they know they won't get
knocked the [__] out are you like that's
really what it is you're like are you
like such a knockout [__] that you you
can't handle the woman talking to you
some type of way like
yeah that's what he said he said knocked
out well and also she did talk to him
that way and he didn't do anything yeah
he didn't write about it so exactly wait
what man like
God damn I feel like this incel super
hardcore instill is like having a
massive uh comeback like this awkward
like
someone's saying this in public that's
great I know it is you're so scary
that's the problem it's actually scary
Abba and preach are moderate only
because there's dudes like this or like
yeah you should be able to beat up your
girlfriend I'm saying it
I feel like shit's getting more extreme
have you found the original one I'm
looking for like I'll hear this on like
a [__] super like random tweet of
something personal foreshan or whatever
like you you don't like whatever right
yeah these people seem somewhat normal I
guess but yeah that's the scary part
about it yeah what the [__] that's why
he lives in Japan
I don't know of course they are right no
I mean yeah it's a weird thing
all right well uh this clip is tough
considering I don't have the first one
but maybe I'll just move on
to my last thing the moving on to uh
wrapping it up yeah but there's one more
thing
yeah there's one last thing
um as we wait for
Abe to find that original clip
oh we're looking for the original clip
yeah okay of the pot of the podcast
portion
yeah at the beginning of that clip
before I cut away to the I have the
original Tick Tock I was trying to find
the the full video but
oh you found it here
it's very very young
it has kids
like 18 19 20 a year into the
relationship it gets really really
abusive even though it might be rare
from what you guys think if it would
happen what would you recommend for
those people were they divorce or do you
want them to keep going in the
relationship you can't divorce and
that's not a real thing even though it
might be like physically abusive you got
to endure it you wanna stick
and then the wife starts cheating do you
think they should divorce
Jesus himself said in in cases of
adultery divorces do you think the
divorce is worse than physical abuse
for the children yes
does people live on I guarantee first of
all you being anyone's dad is going to
damage them beyond all uh they think
that a kid saying their mom being abused
is healthy that's how they were raised
apparently and look they turned out fine
yeah they turn out so fine
yeah there's people that think that
divorce is crazy this is so sad it's so
sad it's like God I like when the guy
went divorced no that's not a thing no
nobody get beaten uh to the she's about
to die and her kids are watching and
basically endure just nothing but if
she's cheating I'm out yeah yet Jesus
said I could so well so I'm gonna go
it's in the Park yeah look if that's the
way to get away from him I'd go [__]
I'd be out in the bar [__] everybody
oh my God on every dick in the bar and I
love how he's like wait what do you mean
for the kids is it worse for the kids
like what are we talking about
it's better for the kids to be raised in
a two-parent home instead of seeing
their uh one of their parents being
divorced [__] insane
oh my God uh Zach I don't know what's
going on with you
oh
I kept being like Zach play this play
this I'm juggling a lot of [__] I like
running a lot and then I'm sorry didn't
nobody poke Zach no I got poked all
right oh I'm sorry I'm juggling a lot of
things no it's not your bad I just I
need some creaks
Zach and door
I'm trying to set this joke up but it's
not it is it never it's never working it
is funny I will say even when you did it
like when you were like I was gonna do
the bit and then you did it it was still
funny
it was yeah I like that
I keep wanting to be like oh here's the
squeaking again
you know
but it's just never it's never played
out in the right way
but you can go ahead and play it some
more Jack
we'll work on it oh man here it comes
the squeaking again
you guys know what that means
I don't wanna I don't want to but
the squeaky wheel gets the oil
you know what I mean it's not your fault
it says it in the book of uh Jonas um 67
line line five it says you got to talk
about how I preach listen I'm gonna keep
it real fast
when I talk about Advent preach because
I know you guys hate it I'm Gonna Keep
it tight and I'm Gonna Keep It Fun watch
this we even made a special edit uh cam
did got into the workshop and made some
really special stuff now before we get
into that there's gonna be less than 10
minutes you can time me
in fact I invite you to time man if
anybody doesn't want to watch this you
guys no no don't say that indoor yeah
that's say that indoor I think you're
gonna say leave I said no no don't tell
him no we learned something today and
door damn it indoor there's the prices
throughout
they are exactly thank you love you get
me
um
you remember how
um hold on one sec
yeah chat is telling you to endorsack
sure that's the vet exactly it's not
your I didn't mean to snap at you uh uh
I'm your clock is ticking you're you're
good you are wasting time about them
you're apologizing and all this stuff
I'm not [__] around with the pausing
today you're on your time so speak okay
what's your truth okay so I just want
you this is just a then I'm using my
precious time to tell you Zack that I
love you oh my God I appreciate that and
I didn't I didn't mean to no it's all
good I didn't mean anything it's all
good I mean it you know I mean I'm just
it's all kosher and to endure please
thank you
so you guys you guys remember how
Abba got super angry at me for and
actually well I asked her
that sounds like essay because he lifted
her top without her consent to make fun
of her and then made fun of her boobs
right and you were like that sounds like
essay yeah and he admit to it
he said yeah I did that [__] she had
lopsided titties he said that and then
Abba goes
you're the biggest piece of [__] in the
world how dare you level fake claims you
are the a monster I mean he had all
these Choice words
check this out okay
this is awesome
you guys are gonna love this let's go
you know I'm telling you this is gonna
be worse than you guys this is how long
ago is this from one year okay good
because you guys could totally still be
cool after they're talking about fresh
the fresh and fit beef they have yeah
that you guys made and it could have
still been really good for content if
you guys had just gone back and forth
and talked about it and it didn't have
to be this sort of life or death I can't
be cool with people who don't have
integrity that's me personally I won't
go after you but if you're someone who I
think is a reprehensible person I'm not
trying to have business relationships
with you
what am I going to spend my day
socializing with somebody who's like a
rapist
so you're saying that about fresh and
Faith yeah let me roll that back
I haven't integrity that's me personally
I won't go after you
but if you're someone who I think is a
reprehensible person I'm not went back
too far spend my day socializing with
somebody who's like a rapist
wow
with a hard R I didn't even say that
he just called him a rapist which is
crazy you know why he's calling him a
rapist because he exposed him for
telling women not only that we meet and
speak once but look at her telling women
that come on the show they have to sleep
with him Myron and they called him out
for it and yet somehow the idea when
it's casually brought up on our show
that he did was
inappropriate yeah they this this this
thought is inconceivable to him but look
listen to what he said about him this
[__] guys the reason why I flip out on
this guy look at all the hip pieces they
made on US 20 plus videos talking [__]
wow he makes this accusation right here
my other voice you won't [__] me then
you can't get on the platform so wait
you want to bang a girl who just wants
to come on the platform for clout and
you think that's burning desire
so he shows a text message I don't need
to listen to my run I mean he's a
[__] [__] but
but I'm like dude what the [__] this guy
defended fresh he called him a rapist
and he knows that he's messaging women
saying if you want to come on the show
you have to sleep with you yet somehow
when I have it it's content
then he's got a defend fit is that it's
not weird to you so this is like a
little bit bad face it is right also
because of what he said to the other guy
where he's like if I if somebody has
like bad morals yeah I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna do anything with them right so
why not side with you on this topic
because I just looks stupid because it
gets a lot of views but like dude you
said he's a rapist in that
you're such a hypocrite dude it's
embarrassing
thank you I just thought that was good
is it not good it is good they said
Ethan you made us defend this dude you
made them defend fresh and fit and then
he he made this whole big Point like
look you accused him of [__] you accused
him with [__] and here he goes he's like
yeah yeah he's a rapist you don't even
you didn't even use that word by the way
he tried to in his response he tried to
explain he wasn't talking about fit shut
the [__] up be a man right that's what
you're into owing your [__] you loser
[__] you're obviously talking about fit
it's like it's like
there's no other way to interpret who
else was he talking about there's some
some loose races running around we don't
know about it we went back and watched
it he's 100 talking about fit okay so
thank you for that ABBA you giant
hypocrite weirdo freak good job
defending who you in your own words is a
rapist
against me apparently who's a
supports women you
which apparently is worse what a [__]
[__] but that's not all and I still
have five minutes so don't freak out
this is a fan edit
this was pretty funny because they you
know how they hit uh
Olivia with the sad violin when she was
like
pouring her heart out yeah they think
they can come before her girl so so
somebody on their subreddit did it a
little bit to them men need to think
that's pretty good because more and more
men are checking out it does checking
out of schools wait hold on you gotta
hit that Jordan Peterson fights during
this Zack men need to hear that because
more and more men are checking out why
check out schools check out diplomas
promise you this in 20 years you're
gonna see those Graphics that was
awesome I think the polarization will
continue I think impossible thing to be
for the distance
okay but here's the one that me and cam
made this is my special uh dedication
for the day all right and you guys are
not going to take this away from me I
said listen I didn't want this I told
Abba and his dumb friend you can you can
tell him what I said Abba
actually because this video is about uh
reach
the one that we made and this is the
edit original I said listen I don't want
this
but you but you know I'm crazy I told
him that I I can't let [__] go and now
all of a sudden he wants to erase his
videos and pretend like there's nothing
happen but I don't let [__] go that's
the crazy thing I tried to tell him that
and like you guys don't want to watch it
and I don't want to talk about it
well yeah here I am talking about it and
that this is the problem I try to say
listen this isn't good for anybody right
not good for you guys it's not good for
even my show
yeah here I am and guess what
I'm not stopping anytime soon
not for you guys and not for you guys
well less than two minutes
I'm a real woman and I'm gonna endure
endure damn it I don't give a [__] this
this is out of my hands
[Music]
good so like this is just beginning this
is just the beginning of me having fun
with y'all and and trust me it is going
to be fun and here's Cam's edit this is
awesome we got a clip we I was joking
about how reach is really dumb
and we found one take in one of their
videos that was so monumentally dumb and
I'm actually shocked they left it in he
is fully incoherent he is the coconuts
and Barbados of having preach and and
with that I give you this masterpiece of
cams and real quick sorry go ahead for
context they're talking about people
making fun of Jordan Peterson crying is
the God okay of course they are love it
so I give you
two seconds my my beautiful art with Cam
[Music]
for the people that are talking to the
people that they deem not tolerant are
not being tolerant themselves you got to
be tolerant I can't tolerate that you
shouldn't be why do we why does he even
why does he even have a platform
whenever we talk about burning the witch
[Music]
yeah keep thinking buddy you'll get
there you know the era where we used to
burn the witch
that Aaron never really stopped the type
of which we was burning changed
couldn't get at them intellectually so
you're gonna get at them with name
causes and [__] and being called like a
fascist and this and that when you're
just trying to comprehend
and in order to comprehend you're gonna
have to break some
comprehend in order to comprehend to eat
the uh the omelet of knowledge you're
gonna need to break those egg shells
eggshell
[Music]
omelette
I didn't see Dan laughing laughing
should have just played that video that
was beautiful no I we made something
funny you so you see I can make it fun
for you guys and that's my pledge and
we're out of time and I did it at the
end of that it was exactly a 10 minutes
perfect
but I'll tell you I meant to do that at
the beginning so you guys got lucky it
was at the end instead of addressing
your criticism they're going to respond
with a compilation of you mispronouncing
stuff that's gonna be wow whatever yeah
wow so original yeah I've been actually
I've been waiting for someone to put
that compilation together it's not like
we don't joke about it all the time I'm
dyslexic so more ableism
actually they're not going to respond
you know why
um because I tried to tell them
they don't want to do this with me
anymore
they made eight videos and it was all
fun because I never acknowledged them
but now that I made a video response
they don't want to do it anymore with me
they're not gonna respond
they're not gonna they're gonna
don't exist what is it worth all the LIE
with a good question
timer at right now the timer's gone
this is what I'm saying either Never
Gonna respond
he's flaring up there was a moment
I gotta tell you I gotta find it there
was a moment last time when you were
talking about them yeah
there was like one sentence when it was
all like using Code words for things and
I was laughing so hard at it I gotta
find it hold up give me that time
she's pulling another clip of me talking
about them
yeah but I don't think they're gonna
respond because they don't want this I
don't know it's not fun for them anymore
of knowledge you've got we gotta crack
the omelet of knowledge where do I get
an omelette of knowledge I was watching
that
we had to assemble a few clips and that
one I was like
yeah that is utterly breathtaking eggs
just like they appeared out of nowhere
we gotta crack the eggs and make the
omelet of knowledge the witches we never
stop burning them
the age of the witches no we never stop
the age
thank you Frankie says that video was
worth it and it's just more there's
gonna be more to come it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be so fun
Ila's uh
so you want to maybe they can help you
find it I don't know how they can help
me so much K-8 says tell your YouTuber
up we're still crashing I tell them I
don't know how they're not fixing this
you guys I don't give a [__] if someone
has time over make posts on YouTube like
support forums I know it's lame but it
also that's good also tweet at Team
YouTube yeah they checked that [__]
using ela's name Pander and Creek that
is really good is this it it might be
here um try to open 139 and 38. can you
oh Jesus me okay actually let me let me
copy the [__] here I'll send it no I got
it I got it I got it
I I am not uh sure if this is exactly it
but I think it is
you gotta grab omelet of knowledge that
one's resonating Zach sure
and then please please grab an endure
yeah okay sure I'll pull it no it's just
really like a chip or sure it was nice
I saw someone in fact say that they're
they're more of an eggs Ben
CH with the scramble of knowledge with
cheese yeah gotta crack the eggs
okay here's Ila's uh moment I I hope
that this is it because I was watching
Babble and squeak I realized how much
reach wait baby so it's like the whole
sentence you gotta keep watching all
right let me go back
the more I watch Babble and squeak I
realize how much reach has in common
with coconuts and Barbados
they
uploaded a video about me how could you
even understand that without so much
context like I used two different names
I understood yeah it's true
do you guys prefer Babel or Pander and
squeak
or Babylon Ridge I think they're all
good I'm kind of nostalgic for peaches
and cream nowadays
I'm with you but are you serious after
everything you've been through on me it
grew on me yeah I told you there was
something to it
I'm all in on peaches and girls oh my
God
I never hated it I never hated it just
for the record but there were some
people that didn't like it and we were
going to a war with them so it's too
sexy man I don't know I feel like it
just it describes them very well I
thought that one was really funny Babble
and squeak that squeak is funny
yeah tweaking is really all he does just
like oh yeah all right that's it guys
thank you we'll have more next week for
sure of course
um they can't keep up with the volume
they can't
you know you might say that he cracked
my egg
and once you crack the egg
you can't put it back together again
even despite all the king's horses and
All the King's Men
they couldn't put me back together again
and I tried I was a strong egg
episodes they make and now that my ass
has been cracked I'm about to become the
Egg of knowledge on your ass
with some cheese on top some olives
oh
you're gonna like the way these eggs
taste boy
scramble them up with some butter real
nice
[Music]
maybe an omelet with some monster cheese
in the middle
you know what I'm talking about
hot sauce
all right that's enough thank you guys
we'll see you on a Monday have a great
week right this is normal week yeah have
a great weekend
uh we love you all thank you for being
here thank you to our members thank you
for watching look out for a new Vlog
this weekend you look liners and thank
you uh to God
for saving the uh murder slash rapist
all things are possible with God
uh oh yeah and Gabe uh shout out to Gabe
who's gonna be sitting behind home plate
keep her eyes open for your boy Gabe
okay
and uh
crack those eggs in knowledge all right
and watch out for those witches
because the age never stopped
they're still burning them
you know who the witches are now man
[Music]
what you have to do
you can you can fade out
[Music]
oh